carlo ravelli is a world-renowned
theoretical physicist and is one of the
main developers of loop quantum gravity
the main academic competitor to string
theory click on the time stamp in the
description if you'd like to skip this
intro it's rare that i feel such a
connection with someone from the get-go
and i hope that you can feel the warmth
of the relation between us as well today
speaking of relations we cover the
argument that relations are more
fundamental than that which is being
related we also cover the only two
interpretations of quantum mechanics
that are consistent at least according
to carlo the nature of time and its
ostensible arrow as well as how science
supervenes on what's decidedly not
scientific per se that is a largely
philosophical conversation there's only
been one book that i've consistently
recommended on this channel and that is
ian mcgill christ's master and his
emissary and now i'm adding a second and
that's carlo rivelli's order of time
links to both of those will be in the
description for those of you who are new
to this channel my name is kurt
jaimungle i'm a filmmaker with a
background in mathematical physics
dedicated to the explication of what are
called theories of everything from a
theoretical physics perspective but as
well as delineating the possible
connection consciousness has to the
fundamental laws of nature provided
these laws exist at all and are knowable
to us if you enjoy witnessing and or
engaging in real-time conversation with
others on the topics of psychology
neurobiology physics consciousness free
will god and so on then do visit the
discord and the subreddit the links for
those are in the description there's
also a link to the patreon in the
description that is patreon.com
kurt jaimungle as the patrons and the
sponsors are the only reason i'm able to
do this full time it would be near
impossible for me to have conversations
like this with any fidelity with any
depth on topics like consciousness loop
quantum gravity geometric unity that's
coming up string theory non-neural
bioelectric manipulation and so on if
not for the patrons and the sponsors
thank you and again that link is
patreon.com kirchheim uncle speaking of
sponsors there are two the first sponsor
is algo algo is an end-to-end supply
chain optimization software company with
software that helps business users
optimize sales and operations planning
to avoid stockouts reduce returns and
inventory write downs while reducing
inventory investment it's a supply chain
ai that drives smart roi headed by amjad
hussein who's been a huge supporter of
this podcast since near its inception
now omdat has a podcast on ai in
consciousness and if you'd like to
support this channel that is the tow
channel then please visit the
description and support his channel as
doing so supports this indirectly the
second sponsor is brilliant brilliance
illuminates the soul of mathematics
science and engineering through these
bite-sized interactive learning
experiences brilliance courses explore
the laws that shape our world it
elevates math and science from something
to be feared to a delightful experience
of guided discovery you can even learn
group theory which is what's being
referenced when you hear that the
standard model is contingent on u1 cross
su-2 cross su-3 those are technically
called lead groups and those are local
symmetries visit brilliant.org toe that
is t-o-e and i think you'll be greatly
surprised at the ease at which you can
comprehend subjects you had previously
had a difficult time grocking don't stop
before four lessons thank you and enjoy
this curiously metaphysical conversation
with carlo revelli yeah when you asked
me i looked i i decided to watch one
and then i said i liked it oh thank you
my physicist i knew i think but i
appreciate the
the width of your the the
um of your questions and uh
and the fact that you went uh very
detailed but you know
a good uh
uh
um
uh middle ground so you you seem to know
what you were talking about yeah i seem
to i'm great at pretending
so professor why don't you explain your
relational view your interpretation of
quantum mechanics
uh wonderful thank you kurt for for
having me here uh first of all please
don't call me professor everybody calls
me carlo and that's how i feel
comfortable with
right so relational quantum mechanics is
um the way i think
it's
i think it's more interesting to try to
understand quantum mechanics there are
as you know kurt there are a number of
uh interpretations of quantum mechanics
out there
i find them all interesting um i think
that none of them it's wrong um i think
they're all each one
is right
but each one has a cost a price to pay
and the question is uh are we ready to
pay this price is it useful to pay this
price to to go ahead and better
understand the world
and uh
i think the the relation quantum
mechanics which i'm gonna describe in a
moment uh uh also have a price like
everything
a philosophical price okay
uh but i think it's the best price to
pace if we if we buy that then we
understand the world better
um
the
the mystery of quantum mechanics can be
can be expressed in different manners um
one way of of of presenting it is that
what the what the theory gives us
is what we see when we look when we see
when we measure it give predictions for
measurement
uh and that's the way it's it's uh it's
formulated in in textbooks uh
the textbook quantum mechanic talks
about the observer we talk about the
measurement apparatus they talk about uh
um
about the outcome of the
of the measurement
now
uh this is okay if you want to use it in
fact a lot of people use quantum
mechanics in these terms and uh very
happy period there's no no question
after that but of course it's not okay
uh if we
after we've realized quantum mechanics
100 years old after we've realized that
uh uh quantum mechanics is actually the
best thing we have for everything for
galaxies for star for for
structure formation in the universe for
what happened inside the sun
so it's it's how we want to think about
the world
at the
most fundamental physical level that we
have access today
and then
what the hell is an apparatus
and an observer doing into that there
are no observers in the sun or or in the
early universe when star formed
so something is missing obviously in the
standard textbook presentation of
quantum mechanics which is who is
observed uh what what is a major what is
a measurement
and one way of saying that is that uh in
the in the in the standard presentation
of quantum mechanics there are two
postulates two assumptions
which appear to be contradictory to one
another one is that um if you don't look
you have a quantum system it evolves in
a way uh which is described by the
schrodinger equation or by unitary
evolution
things change
if you look there is a different
postulate which is a projection
postulate that says that the state does
not evolve schrodinger evolution but it
just jumps
um and the visual way of viewing this is
that
a particle uh like an electron is
described like a wave
that satisfies the schrading equations a
wave diffuses in space when you look at
it you see in a point so the wave
collapses in a point
and when does it collapses when there's
a measurement
and when is a measurement when observer
and a parameters
uh measure it
but
there are no observers a parata inside
the sun no observer apparata inside the
distant galaxy or
in all the cases we use quantum
mechanics so that's the problem
and
there are
many solutions on the table um some
people think that uh you know
it's always waves so the particle never
goes to a point and the
reality will happen is that we are self
waves and we split in many different
copies of ourselves this is many world
interpretation
and others
now the relational
and i'll finally come to you to your
question the relational interpretation
is idea that we can make sense of that
by simply thinking
that what happens between the particle
and the observer
the particle and the measurement parata
is generic and it's not because of
special property of the server or the
measuring apparatus just what happened
between any
system and any other system in the
universe
so every time two systems we describe
the world uh by splitting it in systems
physical systems like the sun like a
particle the molecule
uh the earth uh you me these are all
systems
from the perspective of physicists
every time two of these interact so
exchange something
uh
one so to say measure the other
so if this is a particle
when it interact with me the particle
collapses in a point has a position
okay
but
this is not true
this is only true the positive particles
of pollution only with respect to this
system not with respect to the rest of
the universe
so if somebody else in the universe uh
it's uh uh
it's uh it's later interacting with a
particle and this observer here
doesn't have to take into account this
collapse
so the collapse and the unit of
evolution are always both true
good postulate for describing what
happened
in the universe you just refer
to different
systems
the ones which are directly interacting
what is relevant is a projector
postulate the ones which are not
involved interacting which still
may have an interesting of you know
computing what's going to happen next in
the interaction to them
um
for them is relevant to unitary
evolution postulate
so
the
this is it i mean this solves completely
the quantum mechanical problems because
uh
now we know what is a what is a system
and now what is an observer nothing
special all systems are
systems all system observable
and now we know when to use one poster
than the other
the price to pay is that the practical
being in a position
it's only relative to the system it has
interacted with not relevant to
something else with respect to something
else is still spread around still a wave
everywhere
so
all the variable taken values always
relative relative to a system
so this means
that when we describe the world
uh we describe the world
giving values to variable i means
microphone is here that color on the
screen is red
you know the sun is there these are all
variables that
values the variables take
the color the position
etc
these if you if you buy the relational
interpretation of quantum mechanics they
are not absolute
properties of a system
they are properly the system respect to
me or with respect to this chair not me
as a human being
me as a physical system
so that's a religion relational because
uh
the suggestion here is don't think
at reality
as
systems with properties
rather
think of reality
as a system that
have properties where they interact with
something else only when they interact
with something else and relatively to
this something else
that's a solution a possible solution of
the quantum mechanic
puzzle
um
the cost of this is accepting
uh
this weakened realism so to say the
world is not made by a substance with
properties
it's made by interacting pieces
and the pieces have properties only with
interact
okay so firstly let's remove the word
observer and say interaction because
observer seems to imply in people's mind
a human being essentially or something
conscious
okay exactly
so there's that and then
what i'm wondering is let's say so i
have a bedroom here and i don't know
what's going on pretend it's much
farther away and i haven't interacted
with it so something's going on in that
bedroom now to those people who are
interacting in this bedroom right now
they're
their properties are defined they're
they've collapsed their wave function in
a sense okay that's good is there and
let's say they've come up with some
value and that says
it could be a or b and they've come up
with value a for some like the heads
heads on a coin now is there a reason
that necessarily if i was to interact
with them that it consistently comes up
with the same answer
or is that not necessarily the case
um
good
uh
yes
there is a reason and
but but one has
has to be careful in in formulating
things properly
properly
namely
um
if you uh
let's see exactly what what it means
uh
suppose you yourself measure that
property and and you found a
and then you interact with them
and ask them hey what have you seen
then for sure
you would get something consistent
uh
this is the precise meaning of
seeing the same thing
in other words
you can compare what
what you have seen and what the the
the people in the room have
seen
by talking to them or by asking them or
by measuring them
but this interaction is quite mechanical
so
this interaction is
itself a physical interaction not
outside physics you cannot out go
outside the world and somehow
uh
cheat physics circumvent and say oh
physics is not looking let me ask you
what you've seen that's you cannot do
that's the point
so um
yes there is consistency and why i am so
careful in saying that
because uh quantum mechanics is tricky
as you know if you measure the position
of a particle then they measure the
momentum you destroy
the information about the position
immediately after you measure the
position again it's not the previous one
so but measure the momentum the position
is affected
so you have to be careful because if you
ask these people a question which is
like the momentum toward the position
you might be destroying
uh
some
of the
of the properties
and it might be
therefore
neither true nor false that the value
is a
like when you
when you do a double slit interference
if you measure the interference you
cannot ask anymore which way the
particle has gone through which slip the
particle has gone to so by asking when
there is no answer to the one to the
other one
so
the point is that when you when you
compare what two different observables
have seen you have to be careful that
there are these interference effects
that might create
a
a different
my in my block the possibility of
identifying exactly what what the two
have seen so as long as you keep asking
questions
uh
which are not like position moment that
don't destroy previous information
everything is consistent every observer
sees the same world
with regard to these relations i've
heard you say quite a few times
relations are what are more fundamental
than the things itself
however to me as i'm having a difficult
time understanding that because to me a
relation presupposes things you can't
have a relation without having things to
have a relationship with unless you have
a relation between relations and then it
just keeps occurring infinitely
so
so how is one supposed to think of
relationships as fundamental
see even mathematically the way that i'm
thinking about this right now in model
theory you have a signature and then
relations
you need an arity functions like how
many are are going to be compared how
and then what is being compared are i
would call the things
and then the relation needs those things
so help someone as confused as myself
understand what is meant by relations
are more fundamental than the things how
is it not presupposing
things per se
yeah well it depends what we mean by
thing uh that's uh that's the subtlety
namely um if
[Music]
uh we we're talking about quantum
mechanics so you're not talking about
general philosophical view of what so i
i'm i'm just saying what this
interpretation quantum mechanics
requires us to do
all right
so in this individual quantum mechanics
the basic notions
are
a
system
systems
okay so i'm not
denying
it it's not an interpretation that
denies that we describe the world in
terms of systems okay if you want to
call a system a thing that's fine those
are things okay
this is a system
a pencil okay
and then the relation of between systems
the things that happen between systems
in which a
pension has a color with respect to me
now why is a relation
because this this
this pen is is yellow
but what does it exactly mean that is
yellow yellow is not a property of the
pen by itself it's a property of the of
the pen that depends on the light that
bounces it the interaction with the
light and the the the peculiar uh uh
uh detectors in my eyes
uh which do not distinguish many
frequencies but do distinguish some
frequency and so in terms of this
space of colors which is not outside in
the world is in my head
i call yellow
uh the way this pencil interacts with
the lighting with me
so the being yellow of the of the pencil
it's really something we only understand
if we bring into the picture also the
light and me and my brain and the
specific
three kind of detectors of light in my
eyes and so on so forth good so this
this is an example of a relation to be
yellow is it's a relation sense
now
uh why i said well depend what you mean
by a thing because if by a thing you
mean a an entity with a set of
properties
okay this is a pen is here has zero
velocities oriented up and down with
with a point down
uh uh it's a certain thickness and uh a
certain mass a certain weight and uh um
and a certain position so on and so
forth
if by thing you mean this system with a
given set of properties that it has
then in relation quantum mechanics that
is wrong
because all these properties do not
belong to the
to the pen it belongs to the interaction
depending on whatever it's outside
so in relation quantum mechanics they're
systems and and uh
and and and relation to a system
the properties of a system are all the
relations
but what we when we describe the world
we're talking about the properties
not talking about the systems
we are saying well the moon is there a
position the position is relational with
respect to something else
all properties are relation in in
in quantum mechanics
so it's not that uh the only relations
in relation quantum mechanics is that uh
systems have no properties unless
uh relation
except relational properties are not
properties by themselves
having said yes one is tempted
uh and and many philosophers want to do
that and i have some sympathy for them
to make one step further
uh michelle bit bald is a good example
that his immediate reaction to a
racial quantum mechanic said well why
don't you take one step further
and say well for forget the system the
systems are just the
uh intersections so to say
between between relations
and you say this is hard for you to
conceive because it's a relation
required to think that's true
but uh
you know
think of a network a net a net of a
fisherman
you can say it's a set of nodes
attached by little links
fine
but you can say it's just the links
the notes come just as a peculiar point
where
the links are attached to one another
so uh it's the same with a graph more
abstractly you can think of you can
define a graph in two ways you can say
it's a set of points
and then
relation between the point i mean there
is a there is a link between two points
that simulation or not
or you can say it's a set of links
and then you say who's who is
which one of the link joined to the
other
so you can start from the point of start
from the links to to think of a graph
and so in that sense you might want to
uh just
view the systems as just nodes
of networks after all
uh we never see the moon we see its
properties
so our direct contact with the world is
through uh the properties of this object
from which we construct the object
some philosophy might want to go
all that way uh i have some sympathy but
i don't think that the malaysia
interpretation quantum mechanics uh
requires that relation with the quantum
mechanics in terms of systems
and uh relational properties between the
systems
no okay so you said that we can describe
a system or a system of that's a graph
let's say in terms of treating the edges
as primary or the vertices is primary
and then you can infer correct okay so
exactly is there a reason that
it seems like
because they're interchangeable you
could place emphasis on anyone why is it
that you're
choosing or why is it that it's better
to place emphasis on the relations
rather than the notes the edges right
i think we can do both
i think i think both are doable as far
as quantum mechanics is uh
it's concerned
i
i think the key point is not their only
relations the key point is that
properties are only relational
i see i see you see so how is one is one
not supposed to even vision like i'm
gonna ask how is one supposed to
visualize this
non-property laden node
because as soon as i can visualize i
feel like i've assigned a property to it
so what is meant by this
what is meant by what's being related
is it and is it physical what is meant
by physicality like what the heck is it
now also by the way you can answer as if
it's the spin network like you i don't
know is it that is that what you're
ultimately claiming or is it something
even more fundamental you're unsure of
mathematically how it looks like
take this question any way you like
uh
well
thanks for bringing up the spin networks
um
no i think one
one thing is interpretation of quantum
mechanics
and and the difference the spin net will
come from a different story which is
quantum gravity
uh now
uh let's say on the interpretation
quantum mechanics which is what you're
asking about uh
is one important point quantum mechanics
is not a theory about the world it's a
collection of theories about the world
there is a quantum mechanics of a
particle it's a quantum mechanic of the
standard model there's a quantum
mechanic of gravity which is quantum
gravity uh you know there's a quantum
mechanic of harmonic oscillator there's
a quantum mechanic for the molecule
there's a quantum mechanics of the early
universe
quantum mechanics of the of the of the
what happens inside the sun
so uh quantum mechanics is not a list
of of things out there in the world
uh to have a list of things out there in
the world you should
choose a particular quantum theory
okay not quantitative in general but one
particular platform so quantum mechanics
says okay what is it quantum mechanics
quantum mechanics says that any theory
of the world okay
can be formulated in this way there's a
non-community variable maybe there's a
hilbert space there's some mathematics
of the structure of the mathematics
then you have to say
which variables which
hamiltonian
which
things you describe in that sense um
quantum mechanics is like classical
mechanics classical mechanics is not
a theory of particles
it's theory of anything of a pendulum of
particles of the electric field of
whatever it's just
then it's just a general framework
within which
then you have to specify your variables
face space lagrangian liquidity or
motion
whatever
all right
so uh
if you want to know
how do we currently describe the world
you shouldn't ask what does quantum
mechanics say you should ask what is in
the standard model what is the general
relativity what are the ingredients
of the worlds of the world
so if i do
let's take the simplest case if i do the
quantum mechanic of a particle
okay it's a schrodinger equation of a
single particle
uh
how do i think the system
well it's a particle
it's just this particle and how do i
visualize the system exactly the the
classical way i visualize a particle
there's a particle moving there and if i
do an electromagnetic field i think the
electromagnetic field or many photons
and if i do the standard model i think
all the complexity of the field for the
standard model of the particles animal
now the point is
that let's say on the part of the
particle
i visualize a particle
okay but
i have to remember that this
entity this system the particle
has a position here
with respect to me in the moment is
interacting with me i should not think
that it always have a position
the position is the way the particle
interacts with me
so if i interact with a particle and
there's a wall with two two holes and i
interact again with a particle the other
side of the wall i should not think that
the particle always had a position
and therefore had to choose one hole or
the other
particle might pass through the two
holes because it doesn't have a position
while it's not interacting with me
and when is interacting with me it has a
position so that's it that's the
particle that i see but in that
particular moment not necessarily with
respect to u has a position because with
respect to u it's possible that b and
the particle neither have a position
okay in your description we're both in a
quantum superposition of different
branches of universe whatever
okay so we're not supposed to think in
terms of is or at least it's not useful
i think in terms of relations but also
at the same time i remember in your book
you said nature is what it is
so how am i supposed to make it it is
nature is what it is but then let's not
think in terms of is
am i just taking that a bit too
literally
well it is
do i say nature is what it is nature is
what it is in the sense that
i
i think we often
make a mistake
of
confusing
relationality with subjectivity
um
let me make a simple example in special
relativity or in galileo relativity
we always say the position the velocity
with respect to one observer
okay
um
if i am on the train the velocity of
something somebody sitting next to me is
zero with respect to the observer me but
if you're outside the train the velocity
with respect to you to another observer
is different now we use observer there
but of course this is nothing to do with
the fact that we're human beings we're
thinking right you could say the
velocity of respect to a lump
or there was a respect to a table okay
so a table can be an observer from this
perspective so what we're only saying
that velocity is a relative constant
it's a relational concept it's not a
property of an object it's a property of
two objects there's no velocity of one
object there's only velocity of one
object but the other one
so um
in quantum
i think is similar the the
the properties are relational not with
respect to an observer not respect to
mind
no we don't need mind we don't need to
talk about minds here we're going to
talk about bernardo castro up soon
so don't worry we'll get the mind we
don't we don't want to go to that or we
can get there
there but i i don't think at all that
quantum mechanics take us in that
direction uh it tell us that things are
relational
not the things are relative to mind
um
why this is relevant
to your question because
i
at the light of that i want to think
that i carlo
you curt we're just pieces of nature
they're like tables chairs from this
perspective of course very complicated
we do a lot of stuff that tables and
chairs don't do
but as far as physical properties are
concerned
we're just physical things so
we want to know how nature works in
general on the basis of our experience
of also a limited experience that's the
picture we have about nature and we want
to know how how how work
how digital works with with its
interactions with this
relative variables and that's in the
sense that that's that that's a universe
with its
uh
relational aspects
so for velocity we got used to it
nothing has a velocity by itself
velocity is just a relational thing
since i'm an object i see velocity with
respect to me fine i see that something
is not moving respect to me something
else is but i don't
recognize this as a special point of
view
with respect to
to jupiter
velocity of everything is different
okay
so
it's a story about nature as it is not
about our own
picture of nature
and as always you know
we learn that we're not special we make
a larger picture of reality
we
we think it works
um and that's nature out there
okay let me see if i can summarize so
like you said we take a pen or a cup and
ordinarily we can assign its position
and it's momentum and you're saying well
obviously momentum is relative even
position is relative because that's more
immediate it's two meters away from me
but it's not it's probably thousands of
meters away from you tens of thousands
and so on
okay now what if there are other aspects
of this cup that we think are inherent
in the cup so mass
the amount of liquid in it the
reflective properties and so on what if
those are also relational and for any
conceivable property it's not saying
there is nothing there is no thing
behind the cup it's saying that
whatever we think of as this thing
behind the cup is not what we
i don't know if we can even have a model
of it because our models are so property
laden
but whatever it is it's not what we
precisely think you have a book reality
is not what it seems so reality of this
cup is not what it seems is that correct
yeah it's correct it's exactly so
and exactly in fact one way of seeing is
that uh
quantum mechanics idea of uh
understanding quantum mechanics
discovery that
we always knew that there are many
relational properties out there right
velocity relational
um
but it's a realization quantum mechanics
tell us that all properties are relation
you know firstly
i find you to be extremely philosophical
and much more so than
much more so than the average much much
more so than the average physics
professor i'm curious do you see that
and
and well do you see their first is that
true do you feel that's true
uh i'm happy you asked this question and
uh let me answer
in this way depend on what you mean the
average uh physical professor if you
mean
today's physical professors the answer
is definitely yes
i'm not unique
there are many other like me i mean i
could name many that are
us philosophically or even more
philosophically but the
very very large majority of contemporary
um
physics professors are far less
philosophical however
if you look at the past
um
look uh i don't know 100 years ago in
the in the 20s or
of of the of the twentieth century
um
and if you look just look at the great
scientists at the time uh
schroedinger heisenberg
einstein bore the bulgy they were far
more philosophical than me
they were inspired by philosophy reading
philosophy talking philosophy discussing
philosophy
and that includes newton includes
boltzmann includes maxwell includes
faraday
so um
i think that the
major advances in science in physics
in the past but also i mean in other
sciences
in biology darvin was enormously
philosophical he was a reading
philosopher it was strongly influenced
by philosophers
um
so i think that uh
especially in foundational questions of
course if you
the more you go to to apply to specific
systems you're less
you need i mean
you do need a philosophical mind also
for some
some questions in in more more less
foundational questions but but when
you're close to foundational questions
uh
science in the past in the past i mean
until the 60s no
the past
has been very close to uh
to philosophy philosophy questions
influenced by uh by philosophy and and
talking philosophical terms
um
i mean just read einstein einstein
einstein who is a champion of
theoretical physicist for everybody i
would say
uh he
he has read the three main books by kant
before getting being 16.
he was very he read the hume he read the
uh chopin hour
uh the philosophical writing of poncare
as a philosopher
and
it's obvious once you go into what he
did that everything he did
was very much affected by this
philosophical thinking
so i think uh you're right i am
more
i belong to the to those scientists who
are more philosophical than many others
i think it is a um
a
limitation
of a part of the research today
uh to be
very technical very mathematical very
shut up and calculating
yeah or
or just do mathematical modeling i think
that if you invent a sufficiently
complicated mathematics
uh you bring this and this and this and
this and this very hard mathematics and
blah blah blah and that's you're getting
close to reality
maybe not
you know some people say don't mistake
the map for the territory
is that what you mean or is it
because i think that a lot of uh
current
working theoretical physics is a map
without a territory
ah okay oh without a territory all right
right now max take mark and i haven't
seen his lectures on this but i'm sure
he would object because he has the
mathematical universe as his
philosophical framework
oh
not at all i mean i think max stegmark
who is a thinker i deeply respect is one
of the most philosophical even more
philosophical than me
i mean he's a
he's a philosopher compared to me i mean
he's a guy who wrote a book claiming
that every
um
every possible coherent mathematically
described universe is
as real as the
our actual one
um
that's deep philosophy it has nothing to
do with direct physics in us it's right
it's it's wonderful speculations
max
uh i mean max has a a technical work as
an astrophysicist but has a
a a
range of wide uh
very philosophical speculations i think
we need more people like max
and less people
who
uh
who just do mathematics without really
asking
what is real reality i'm actually
describing here
do you see that there's not only a lack
of philosophical ideation but perhaps a
resistance to it do you see an aversion
to it or do you just see it as they lack
it there's an absence of it
when i say they i mean let's say the
average mathematician or physical or
both both both let's not forget that
stephen weinberg who is a great
scientist of course with major major
results
wrote a book and one of the chapter of
the book the title is against
philosophy and and uh uh stephen hawking
who is a
very good physicist of course and he did
he had important results not as good as
what weimberg but totally very very
important
it's on the record to say many times
philosophy is dead
um because now we have signs that solve
all the problems uh i wish it was true
but it's wrong because it doesn't solve
problems it has a lot of problems by
itself um
and and and so
philosophy is not dead philosophy isn't
constantly interacting with uh um the
reason is
that science is not about uh you know
you make measurement
and then you write it in the equation
and then you check your equation with
the measurement if it is wrong you throw
it away you try another one that's not
the way science works the science is
a constant
changing of the conceptual structure you
use for describing the world
you rearrange things right you call this
together you call this separate you
think differently use different notions
different concepts
uh you know copernicus instead of
seeking the earth the sky you know
there's a mountain the stones in the sky
the sun the moon the planets the stars
he just changed everything he said no no
no that's not the rightest thing there's
the sun and the planets
and the satellites and the planet is the
earth the moon so it's a completely
different rearrangement
of uh
how to organize the world this is this
to
to be able to be capable
of this uh conceptor rearrangements
um
you have to think
what you called philosophical uh
thinking that's the kind of thing that i
stand in the heisenberg did faraday did
boltzmann did
and that's not what is done
by
a lot of theoretical physics we just
think that the only thing you have to do
you know is to write another lagrangian
or
to write another you know
map between a hilbert space and other
hilbert space
or a new set of uh
uh uh
of scattering relations yeah and that's
sufficient is that because they want to
play it safe in a sense because when
you're just theorizing mathematically
it's easy to check where you're right
and wrong whereas if you're
philosophizing firstly you can delve
into pseudoscience and not be aware that
you are and it's much easier to wildly
speculate and be incorrect is that
what's behind it like what is behind the
aversion that you see
i think it's cultural i think it's
cultural i mean many of my colleagues
were raised in the
60s 70s 80s in a moment in which it
became very fashionable
uh to be anti-philosophical
um
this is after the war
uh
the center of science shifted the part
toward the united states from europe
where it was before
uh
a little bit
it's a success of the incredible success
of the physics of the
of the 30s
right the 20s 30s 10th i mean the first
half of the century
i mean the discovery of special
relativity generativity quantum
mechanics quantum field theory
was spectacular uh so good
that then somehow it made sense to say
well stop thinking let's use it
right i mean
we have all these tools that our
forefathers have discovered i mean
that's good let's use it and on the
basis think what has happened on the
basis of
quantum mechanics
uh boom you get you know
uh nuclear physics particle physics con
fundamental condensed matter uh
uh lasers uh
all sort of models just using the
equations with the dial by heisenberg
and company
and on the basis of special relativity
it took a little bit longer so the end
of the century but suddenly you know you
do relativistic astrophysics cosmology
black hole boom gravitational waves
fantastic just on
on the conceptual ground
uh
built in the 20s and 30s
so that the beginning of the century the
physicists were so good
that then people didn't have to think
for various decades just just
apply apply apply apply but then you
need to stop thinking for a while you
get used to not thinking you get used to
the idea that it's just mathematical
complications so if you're sufficiently
mathematically skilled
uh then you will do great physics and
there are people who are
spectacularly mathematically skilled and
do all the others like them like edwin
edward then is
a great mathematician if there's an
alien it's him
yeah but then he drew an entire
community in doing not physics because
if you think for a moment
whitten
has not got any real
physical result right
he has proven the positive energy
theorem
generativity which have improved before
and found a better proof of the positive
energy that's a mathematical game
and then he has you know speculated
about string theory and and
and constructed the
games over games that haven't produced
any physics so far
here's a fun question i'm curious if
you've thought much about it so it's a
def it's almost a question of
definitions
what is the universe so one answer is
the universe is everything that there is
so there cannot be an outside to the
universe by definition
by the way when i'm talking about
definitions it seems like that's there's
no point in talking about definitions
themselves are not profound because
they're tautologies
however when i was speaking to jorah
barnett and i'm not sure if you know him
he was saying kurt you want me to talk
about proofs and theorems what may be
more important are definitions and
techniques
so let's not
let's not demean definitions so firstly
what is the definition of the what is
the definition of the universe and then
where do the laws stand so are the laws
a part of the universe
um
the different definitions of the of the
universe which are useful
um
and uh
it's good not to confuse them because we
we can use both of them um
in cosmology
which is a great discipline which have
made very important
had obtained great results in in the
last decades
uh the universe is not the totality of
thing the universe is the
uh
the description of what we see around us
as the largest scale that we look at it
so
the
that universe is a very small thing
it's lowercase u
it's just not looking at the details
it's what you see if you don't look at
the details but of course the details is
you and i are the details of that right
sure in that picture
uh that's very useful uh it's a very
strict definition of universe and you
describe it you know with a scale factor
that grows in the galaxy density and
this kind of things and dark matter and
and so on and so forth
and
that has turned out to be very very
useful because in fact we have learned
a credible story of what has happened
for 14 billion years in the past and
it's a very credible story i mean it's
very convincing once you study it say
yeah good we have evidence for that
but that's not the universe in the sense
that you were asking right it was
you were referring to a different
definition you would say which is all
there is so to say the totality yeah
tantamount to reality
yeah it's a the the
the the totality of the real things the
the totality of
of realities
uh i agree that definitions are
um
not
are important accusations yeah they're
not revealed they're not trivial i think
in some sense they are but they give
extreme insight yeah they're great
inside i mean think of the example of uh
i talk about copernicus right if you
start by a definition
you know of uh
earth
and and and the celestial bodies
you you you're done you killed
copernicus right you have to redefine
things you have to define planets versus
stars versus satellite and then you go
ahead without this definition you're
lost and then it's a very
uh
unintuitive definition planet i mean why
should i put in the same
category
the earth which i see around me you know
with the trees the mountain the sky the
birds and this little dot that move out
there which is venus these are
completely different things right no
they're not different things that's the
point you can define them together and
bingo you understand how the solar
system works so definitions are crucial
now
the tokenity thing it's a
delicate definition
because of relational quantum mechanics
ah so
uh
you see
if you buy malaysia quantum mechanics
you cannot ascribe properties the
totality of things because all
properties are really relative to
something else
so there is no
uh
there is no properties the universe has
no property in fact the universe is is
is not a system because a system is
something which can interact with
another system
to reveal its properties so to manifest
its properties
so you
if you buy a relational quantum
mechanics you only have descriptions of
the units from the inside so to say
just keep your universe as a whole you
cannot have it
so
uh
if you take serious relation quantum
mechanics and if you take seriously uh
what several philosophers today
are telling us
uh
i i think for instance janan ismail is
one of them
that
careful because every time we look at
the universe we'll look at universe from
the inside as being part of the universe
not from the outside and we often get
confused
because we we take it out of the picture
we think that we can
see that totality of things from the
outside and and and that's wrong and a
lot of confusion about i don't know free
will
um
or
um
or
what is knowledge
it's always thinking that we're outside
the universe that's the universe with
its stuff and we are out there looking
at that that's it's not true it's
factually not true
uh so
the universe in the sense of cosmology
is fine it's perfectly good thing but
the universe in the sense of the
totality of thing
uh it's uh it's a notion one should be
very careful with in my opinion for
instance one should not abstract
properties of the universe because how
do
how do you what do you mean this is one
reason i don't believe there is a wave
function of the universe doesn't make
any sense
there are many in principle problems
with conceiving of the universe well in
principle problems with science apply to
the universe as a whole because in
science we're constantly looking at
interacting parts within
and so then firstly how are you supposed
to perform an experiment twice on the
universe as a whole because the universe
is the entirety
okay except you might expand exactly on
that so what are the problems of the er
what else are the problems the in
principle problems not just
pragmatically we can't interact with all
of the universe the in principle
problems with conducting science or even
thought experiments about the universe
as a whole
um
yes uh i can't but
before doing that let me reiterate uh uh
the distinction between the two
different meanings of of universe i mean
when the cosmologists
talk about the universe that's solid
science that's observable the universe
is what is the absolute universe okay
uh
the the universe is a cosmologist so
it's uh
what is it
it's the the large
properties of what we see around us
so uh
we look at that universe from the
outside right we have a telescope with
the telescope we count galaxies
so the telescope and us is the observer
the the galaxy's counted it's the system
we're observing
so it's fine it's it's perfectly fine we
can see this galaxy we see how much
they're moving apart from us we can
trace back
how compressed they were in the before
we have a system we can model it
um
and we're observing these degrees of
freedom uh
from the outside in the sense that we
are not part of those degrees of freedom
we are
especially inside but we are observing
it from not being one of them it's like
if we were i'm in this room and i study
the air of this room i can be inside the
room but i'm not there
okay
so so that's fine on the other hand
uh the idea of describing the totality
of thing of ascribing a wave function
for instance through the totality of
things
which is common
uh
i i don't think it's a good idea
because uh
let's be real specific the wave function
of an object a wave function of this pen
uh it's a way of computing
where this pen is gonna
show up with respect to me next
right right so
when when i'm in a laboratory and and
and and and do some quantum measurement
uh and and i use the wave function the
quantum state for uh predicting what i'm
going to see
uh i i'm deducing this wave function
from what i saw
okay i've seen this pen the spin of this
particle in one way goes to some
apparatus and i have the
probability of the
spin being this way or that way after
the pentagon supply that's a typical
uh super simplified calculation and to
do this calculation i use the quantum
wave function of this
of this uh of this pen but what is this
quantum wave wavefunction
is what i
know about the pen
and it's a
a description
of what should i expect of the pet so
it's something that regard the pen and
me
it's a it's a relative state and the
person who
first has understood
that
when you use quantum states in quantum
mechanics we always talk about relative
space is evident
uh
in
several decades ago uh everett has
understood that states are relative
states so the quantum state of an object
is always relative to another object
okay this is a state is a relational
thing
and once you understand that
clearly
the totality of thing does not does not
have a quantum state
because unless you believe there is god
then god thinks do quantum experiments
on on the but then god is not part of
the universe
then you lose n god together don't have
a quantum state right so um
the
the
the wave function of everything
of the universe in the sense of
everything um i think is not something
that should uh enter in is not a useful
notion in physics the
way functions are relational notions
um that connect a system with another
system considered observing
okay so three thoughts occur to me i'm
gonna say them and then just so that i
don't forget them and then we can tackle
them one by one
okay so number one you mentioned everett
and i believe everett was a proponent of
many worlds i'm in i'm not sure about
that so okay you nodding your head so if
that's the case well if he
in many ways realized this relative
notion of quantum mechanics the
relational notion so why did he move to
many worlds so that's one i'm going to
say the others so don't forget them
number two
when we're speaking even right now just
with the english language it seems
incredibly
misleading because as soon as i say i
look right there i use the word i and
you also mentioned as many philosophers
come to similar conclusions well what is
this i what is behind so as soon as you
start to analyze any word as soon as i
say cup well what is the cup
okay you we realize that
every everyday language is beguiling so
it can't actually describe reality no
i'm wondering
is there something similar with math
do you believe that math is somehow
exempt from this that math is actually
can't math actually can describe reality
so that's my number two don't worry i've
got all these in my head and the number
three was i didn't hear
an answer to
whether or not the laws themselves like
the rules of the game are part of the
game or in other words
if when one thinks of reality as a whole
is one also supposed to think of
the laws that reality operate by as
being a part of reality so let's get to
number one why did everett come to
alternate conclusions yes um so the
first thing you asked is uh um
you said everett is is considered the uh
sort of the beginning of a many world
interpretation that's correct
no that's correct and uh in fact uh many
people who like the many world
interpretation called all calls this
inspiration also the everett interpreter
right i think that's where i got it
called himself
um
everett wrote a
a a fantastic paper plus other uh
other things in which there are a number
of ideas
um we also have the um
the thesis that everett wrote when he
left physics
um
so
one question it might be what he himself
actually thought about quantum mechanics
but that's not a very interesting
question i mean
what is interesting is not what actually
people thought at some time what is
interesting what can we do with the with
their ideas and their text
and everett has introduced this notion
of uh
relational states
which i think is spectacularly good
and one way
of developing that idea is relational
quantum mechanics namely thinking that
properties are all relational
another way of developing that idea
is the many world interpretation so if
you want from evidence you can branch
off to two possible
uh directions of thinking about quantum
theory
the mineral interpretation
it goes the opposite direction than
relational quantum mechanics even if it
has this common idea that properties are
relatively they
many more people will say to to system
into branches
um the the main world idea is is is
contrary is to take
the wave functional universe seriously
and think that this is all there is this
wave function of the universe this
overall
uh super quantum state in which we are
sitting
and uh um
and all the rest has to be sort of
extracted from
uh
derived from from
from
this wave function of the universe
this wave function of everything and
that's a real stuff that's sort of the
main it was interpretation um it's very
interesting
i don't like it very much i think that
as
i said at the beginning each
interpretation is a cost and i don't
think it's a cost
that is bringing us ahead
because uh you know if you think
uh if you if you take it seriously
um
[Music]
the universe is sort of constantly
splitting in multiple
branches of this big wave function
where you and i are copied millions and
millions of times
uh so you always think that there is the
other the other the other copies of
non-realized
uh yeah
you might think that way but it's
nothing wrong but i don't think it's
useful
okay so then number two was about the
limitations of language and then do you
see
any similar limitations to
the language of mathematics to the
degree you can call it a language
as describing the universe
i i don't think mathematics
alone is sufficient
um
[Music]
i mean i i listen and i read max tech
mark but nevertheless i think that
between mathematics and reality there is
a gap
um
i think mathematics is not out there
mathematics is a game we play fantastic
game play super useful
that we extract from
from reality
but i think that
um
if i use case but if i think case by
case the mathematics that describe a
pendulum
okay
which we learn at school when we study
you know the the differential equation
of a pendulum the solution sine or
cosine
it's beautiful mathematic but it's not
pendulum
okay now you can say okay because
something is missing in a real pendulum
there's also this also this also this
but i think it it it stays like that i
mean you refine your model your
mathematical model
but there's a jump
between
there's always a jump between
mathematics and reality and when you
[Music]
when you do
you get to complicated theories like
current physical theory standard model
generativity
it's even stronger i mean these
equations need to be interpreted need to
be connected
to what we see and this connection
it's part of the story and it's even the
most interesting part of the story so to
say it's not sufficient to have
questions at that i mean what does it
mean you have a question we have all
space of solutions
now max stigma could say okay that's
reality that's over all the reason we
just happen to be into one
um
but which one that's that's uh
that's the connection to reality
so this means that also mathematics has
the same problem that you are describing
i mean our
everyday language
might be inappropriate
to describe the world
we have to refine it we have to invent
the new new words planet which include
the earth
but the same is true with mathematics i
mean the fact of writing a big
mathematical equations is completely
insufficient
unless we
uh
interpret
it's its ingredients and we connect it
to the world into our experience
so the
the indeterminacy of language that you
were referring to we have to struggle
with
uh with or without mathematic equally
and we have to live with it we
we should not
uh think that we can
you know get to the bottom of the story
and have a perfectly
logical perfect language description of
reality and everything is clarified
we're not there
completely not there by by the zillions
of miles
we are in a big mess in which we see a
complicated world we understand part of
it we understand some regularities of it
and we call this our physics
um
and this this takes me to the
the third question about the laws
yeah to the third question about the
laws
uh which you asked before um
i think that what laws are
as far as we know
just uh irregularities so
we
we see phenomena
we think that this is the way
uh
uh
nature works so phenomenal not just with
respect to us the phenomena with respect
to
saturn when saturn when something hits
saturn this saturn it's it's hit by by a
meteorite like i'm hit by your voice
uh
the world
it's it's it's it's this is a fact it's
a mixture of two things
of uh
uh contingent thing that we have no idea
how to predict
and predictable things
it's always been like that right i don't
know who will bring my phone next but i
know that tomorrow the sun will rise
i know exactly what time it will rise
okay
so there's a part of the world which is
incredibly easy to predict
i mean if i let this thing fall i know
it will go down and not up i can predict
it i can bet of it and i'm going to win
them it
so there's a huge part of the
world which is predictable and there's a
huge part of the world which is
unpredictable
so we organized that in our science and
physics in particular and we call the
predictable story the laws
that we found out okay this what did
this i mean we found some regularity
very very good very strong regular i
think we call the laws
and we
have unpredictable part which we call
initial conditions or
uh you know and determination in quantum
mechanics we give other names
um to the fact that uh definitely the
laws are not sufficient to describe the
world right or obviously because a
single law has many solutions we don't
know which one describes the world
as an aside
you hear people say well copernicus
realized that the earth revolves around
the sun isn't one of the points of
general relativity to say that you can
actually view it both ways you can just
change the coordinates according to
system technically
okay yeah you're right
yes you're right
you're right in fact
um
in fact
if you ask don't put this way because i
think it's interesting if you ask the
the question um
is is the earth going around the sun or
the sun going around the earth
uh
let me put a simpler question is the
earth the center of the universe
is that a scientific question yes of
course it's a scientific question right
in fact jumping out from this
idea that the center center is what
allowed us to do
newtonian physics kepler and everything
i mean we understood so much
but let's ask let's think about this
question can it be measured whether the
earth is a central universe or not no
right there's no way to measure it we
have no no way of thinking what is the
center of the universe
but it's not
something which is uh directly
measurable
and i think this is interesting because
it shows that science is not just about
measurable things
science as i said before is about
organizing your thinking in some way
so if you organize your thinking as the
earth
not moving everything going around it in
some way
you're just messing up your your
understanding it's just it's too
complicated you're not getting out of it
but if you start to organize things
first is this is
the sun and then say oh no actually it's
not the sun the sun is also moving and
then you better again
um
there's no center in the universe
there's no preferred reference frame um
some up properties some of the other
properties
you
reorganize your thinking in a better and
better ways and of course the previous
one looked a little bit naive always
okay it's not true that the sun is the
center of india is going around it's
more complicated story like the one you
said it's more correct
um
so
science is not about
true or false
it's not just about true or false clear
statement
it's about the best way we found so far
for thinking about the universe
the one that allows us to understand
things to predict thing to write laws
more easily
i think me and you think
quite alike and i heard a hint of it
when you said that there are different
quantum mechanical interpretations and
in some sense they're each right
now that phrase they're each right
that's
i'm not driven by promoting peace even
though it seems like i'm ironic it's
just that
look i i didn't say they're each right i
see i said they're each coherent and
possible
they're not wrong
let me explain so before copernicus
earth center copernicus no sun is
centered einstein hey you're both right
in some way now i'm curious as i
investigate more philosophy even
religion
just like there was this line in your
book about up and down and it seems to
make no sense it seems contradictory
until you view it from another point of
view and you see oh well what's up to
australians is down to us canadians and
so on
okay well i'm als i also see or also
wonder how much of religion and
well philosophy in general but let's
just take religion
it's it seems like
the major religions contradict with one
another but are they true contradictions
when viewed from another perspective is
there another one in which you can say
actually that's right in some way that's
right in some other way and that's right
no okay i've just outlined in a sense my
outlook my personality
do you view problems like that or do you
see what i said as having any truth or
is there something that i should be
aware of as a limitation in that
thinking
well it's it's uh
you bring different things together um
first of all uh
let me separate my answer in two parts
first of all uh
religion is a very complicated phenomena
very very very wide phenomenon
uh
you mentioned the big religion
religions big religions first of all
they're different from one another
they're different properties second they
are institutions their people their
history
their center of powers sometimes the
systems of beliefs they make statement
their moral systems
uh their ways for people for thinking
the world their way of people to getting
together you know you go to the church
and you fight friends
so um
it's uh
it makes no sense to say
uh it's certain religion right or wrong
i mean it's like saying is the united
states right or wrong well it's in my
opinion is wrong in some things like
some other thing
i disagree with some of his politics i
like some of its uh face ideology
whatever so um
so uh
if you isolate within religion
uh certain uh moral
aspect uh
definitely you you
i am not religious at all i'm an atheist
i feel perfectly sympathetic i mean i'm
happy to uh
fight together with some religious
people for the peace in the world i
don't know
um if you isolate some other aspects
uh like the belief that was a creator
which is a person i just find it wrong
i i think it's wrong
so
uh it's a very complicated story and i i
i see a lot of bad in religions i also
see a lot of good religions i i don't
want to enter in which one i think is
strong
um
now let me let me zoom into your your
point uh because you said well does this
mean that tamal
there is always some something right
i
it's more interesting namely
uh i think that we
we humans live in a dialogue
and the good of the dialogue
is that we change our mind because of
what we hear from the other guy right
that's how culture has developed that's
how science has developed
and each time so
we're always
the best thinking
it's always in search of what is wrong
not what is right okay what is wrong
with my thinking what is wrong in your
thinking because that's what allows us
to go ahead right
is
the
the great uh step of copernicus
has not been you know to to to
to
to have the idea that the earth goes
around has been to recognize that being
attached to the idea that the entire
center is wrong
just found something wrong in the
uh
in the basis
of
um
of the way astronomers thought for for
centuries and and you know a couple
generation later ketler
did the same game he discovered that for
two millennia people try to make sense
of what we see in the sky in terms of
circles and he says this is not circles
they're ellipses okay so after two
millennia of circles he said well forget
circles
so what is interesting what we are wrong
okay
and i think there are a lot of wrong
ideas in instead of all
inside a lot of beautiful
moral social
human constructions and behaviors there
are just wrong ideas in many religions
um
it has to be so because they are so
contradictory of one another of course
there's some wrong ideas i mean they
cannot be all right
so the fact that we can learn from one
another and
we can often um
take a larger point of view
on
does not change the fact that there's a
precise sense in which uh
the pre-copernicus system the ptolemaic
system is just wrong factually wrong and
copernicus system is wrong
and
kepler is wrong because
planets don't go along ellipses they
move more complicated and newton's
theory is wrong because if you take
newton's theory
and you
use neutral theory to compute the motion
of mercury just get it wrong
okay you miss a little correction which
comes correct with generativity
so
um
in a sense
uh
i'm
i'm not
i think there is to learn from from
different things i think it's good to
give
keep an open mind and to listen
different perspective
but the interesting of the dialogue is
precisely when we can
step out from mistakes in one one one
situation or the other
see for me when it comes to religion in
particular i would say up until just a
couple years ago i was such an adamant
atheist and i wouldn't say that i'm a
theist now at all i'm i just wouldn't
classify myself as either being pro or
against but say i'm undecided the reason
why i don't focus on the wrong
is because to people like me and and you
scientifically minded people it's fairly
obvious the wrong it's just so blatant i
find it much more interesting and
difficult to see well what is compatible
and what is correct from another point
of view may also that
definitely knowing where one is wrong
even the nuances of incorrectness adds
to certain correctness like gives you
different points of view so let's i
understand that
you know speaking of what's wrong i'm
curious let's imagine if
all properties are relative okay now is
the law that all properties are relative
a property can you be relational with
respect to the principle of relation
what does that even mean does that lie
outside
do you understand what i'm saying i know
this is extremely ill-defined
but i'm always interested in what
happens when a principle is applied to
itself
so even let's say bayesian reasoning
if you ask someone who says i'm a
bayesian reasoner okay so do you believe
anything with 100 certainty they may say
no like i'm a scientist so i okay do you
doubt the principle of
bayesian reasoning even one even a
little even a tiny because as soon as
you open a sliver there then what
happens when you
well
you get what i'm saying
yes of course i get well what you're
saying um
i think that one of the
interesting trends in contemporary
philosophy
it's
what might be called anti-foundation
uh
it's not
a new idea there was
anti-foundationalism in um
thinking
in in western and also in eastern
philosophy um
and this is idea that what does that
mean yeah it's idea that you uh
you don't need to hold
to
um uh
not only to absolute certainty but to
any
to to anything definitive um
is is sort of is a shift is idea of
shifting
from what we can say for sure what can
you say from final
to uh what we can say
um
interesting and and and valuable
um
in fact this is
look uh kurt your your um
your series is about the theory of
everything
i don't think we need a theory of
everything
i i think we need good theories
the more coherent possible the more
uh useful possible more advanced
possible
like pragmatic
as soon as someone says yes i think of
pragmatism like it's all a goal based
whether it's adaptive uh
well maybe it's pragmatic i don't know
it's a
pragmatism
philosophical current has as much more
um
i
i think that
what i like in science and in philosophy
it's the part of them that have this um
uh
this attitude
which is look we can learn it's it's
historically we know what we can learn
we can learn more and more and more but
it's not useful it's useful to ask
as best as we know today what is the
best organization we have of our of of
of the world and it's true that there's
a remarkable coherence in our culture
and our understanding of the world
but asking what is the final
uh ingredient of the world what is the
final rules of thinking
what is the basic substance of
everything it's just a bad it's a
useless question
that's my take
so can we live with uncertainty yes do
we have to take something as
uh
can we doubt our also our doubt sure we
can
it might be useful
i will read from your book to give
people an overview and by the way write
previous to this question i just wrote
down a wonderfully
philosophical set of sentences from you
which was about bryce and john
when you met them and then you felt the
pain of their absence you then wrote but
it isn't the absence that causes sorrow
it is affection and love without
affection without love such absences
would cause us no pain for this reason
even the pain caused by absence is in
the end something good and beautiful
because it feeds on that which gives
meaning to life
if those of you who are watching are
listening
i've recommended only one book
consistently and that's ian mcgill
christ's master and his emissary and i'm
going to start to add a second one and
that's order of time
it's filled with firstly if you want to
know about the nature of time and how
time has been thought of and redefined
or not well
recontextualized is a better way of
thinking about it it's
it's a wonderful wonderful book and it's
quite short so the opposite is ian
mcgill chris which is i think
a tome and then yours is a compendium
it's quite
digestible
okay let's get to thermal time so
firstly i want to
tell you how beautiful
that set of lines were
thank you very much good thank you for
saying that about uh the audio of time
is it's definitely the book which is uh
that i've written which is more close to
my to my heart because uh
it's a book and you know the quotation
you you mentioned uh uh
shows it um
it's a book in which i talk about
science
it's mostly about science
uh and it's about the science of time
and uh and i i sort of try to summarize
everything we know from science about
time
and also the things we don't know uh
about time from from from science so i
it's a big part in which i just
explained at best as i understand
what we've learned about time for
special activity from statistical
mechanics from boltzmann et cetera et
cetera for quantum gravity
um
and then also
the open questions
what we think the speculations
but it's also a book
when i wrote it
time touches us right
we are time is not a neutral thing for
us because
it's what makes us living but also what
we lose time is losing
so time is something that touches deep
us inside so it's it's a book that while
writing it i had constantly this
emotional aspect about time in mind so
there's a lot of poetry in the
versus from horus which is an ancient
latin philosopher which i love which
talks about time the time that passes
the passage of time and there's the last
chapter in which i talk about death
which is the ultimate confrontation with
time that we have in our in our uh in
our life so it's a it's a book which is
science but also
uh our emotional relation with time as
you um
since the quotation you mentioned about
about pain and sore of losing people
all right so sorry for this that's right
in chapter 10.
i think in chapter 10 it's called
mandolin i don't recall the words that
came prior to it but it's about the
eastern mystic from the 100 years 100
first century sorry second century
nagarjuna is that correct
yeah nagarjuna is a chapter well no
there is a chapter in the guardian in
helgeland my book on quantum mechanics
okay so what was being referred to in
mandolin when oh this person said that
there is no i
oh yes yes yes yes that's a famous
dialect in eastern literature the
beginning of the buddhist
philosophy it's a spectacular dialogue
the dialogue about the chariot right
who is he speaking to
uh it's a king king oh i've got the name
sorry i forgot the name
it's it's a it's a it's it's one of the
topics you want to just discuss the
nature of i itself
um but let's go let's keep that for
later
so you asked about terminal time yeah
okay for the people who are listening
the links to carlo rivelli's book order
of time as well as his latest book are
in the description
and well what was super interesting to
me is in 2022 i'll start to delve a bit
more into eastern philosophies i've had
on pretty much zero although most
people's philosophies are influenced by
different parts of the world to some
degree
so this it was fun because when i was
first asking you for an interview
i used it as an opportunity for me to
learn loop quantum gravity
because i've always wanted to learn some
of that so i started going through your
lectures
but then i was sidetracked in the most
positive manner by order of time i just
i just i didn't think that you were such
a philosophical person and i thought boy
oh boy i don't
well i don't know of anyone who
is
a theoretical physicist that
is able to be so
cognitively flexible in that regard you
mentioned max tag mark but i haven't
looked him up much so i was just
i was thrown by that and i was i'm still
super excited to be speaking with you
thank you kurt
um thanks a lot um
so you want to know about terminal time
so can you explain what thermal time is
this is my question and then i head up
as a note so the conventional logic for
interpreting this relation is time
gives you a notion of energy which gives
you a notion of an a macroscopic state
now you're saying that this can be
reversed
okay now that's so using that as a
jumping off point and remember that the
audience understands what entropy and so
on is
though if you want to quickly go over
you're more than welcome to
okay perfect so um
um
there are a number of open questions
uh in understanding time
i think there are a lot of things we
have understood
that time doesn't work for the way we
usually think about because we have
understood this with special relativity
general activity with statistical
mechanics but then there are some open
questions
and
among the
open questions
it's following
once we go
to
a generality relativistic description
about the world
um
the so
description of the world
large enough to include the relativistic
properties of gravity
then the theory we use
does not have a lot of variables
variable things we measure
but none of this
is naturally identified as a time
variable
that's the point
and i'm not talking
for those who are
more learned among those who
you guys who listen i'm not talking
about in a given space time
which one is a time of course in a given
space time there's the clocks that
measure proper time along each line we
know this time
but i'm talking about the
evolution of space-time itself i mean
the einstein equation
that evolved for gravity space-time
matter everything
in that evolution this evolution is
given as relative evolution of variables
and not evolution in time
uh
and then case by case we can identify
say well let's
call this time
one one particular variable this works
um in fact this is the way the world is
at the level of of of generativity
and also at the level of a general
relativistic quantum field for quantum
gravity but then there is something
funny
and that's a question
in our experience it's very clear
uh which variable is time it's it's the
one that clocks are connected to okay
the time value is completely different
than the other variables
profoundly different
and
so
how is it possible that from a theory in
which no specific variable is temporal
then
for us
uh
one variable which is the position of
the clock is definitely completely
different than the others because it
distinguishes pass from the future in
such a way
so i
worked on that
and i wrote some papers several papers
from that and a key paper with a french
mathematician field medal alain khon a
spectacular and brilliant and good
mathematician
because we got to this idea
both of us uh independently in a very
different path and we wrote this paper
together
he came to that from pure mathematics i
came that from think about physics
and so the idea is a speculative idea
i'm not sure is correct uh it's not
something people agree upon but i i put
in the book as a as a speculation it's
something i i think in some sense should
be right
um and there is a following
that
when we distinguish the time variable
from the other
it's because
of of what peculiar time what is
peculiar of time that the past is so
different from the future okay the
right and left are not different up and
down are not so different a little bit
different but we understand that
uh passive future are completely
different
and
but the big difference the the many
differences which we can write down but
the big difference is that entropy grows
toward the
future okay and this is a reason
we remember the pastor not the future
this is the reason the future feels open
this is a reason uh uh
uh if you if you if you sure feel
backward the moving backward is
obviously backwards and so on so forth
so
what characterize a time direction is
not mechanics
is entropy and entropy means statistical
mechanics and means
that we're giving a close grain
description of the world in terms of
temperature entropy so we have many
degrees of freedom and we are
um
we are um
uh
uh not describing all of them but only a
few of them this is what entropy is
about so there's something about the
flow of time which has to do with the
fact that
we don't describe the microphysics we
have this macroscopic description now if
it is so
then
it's very tempting
to
reverse the story
between the flow of time
and
the macro physics okay in in the
following sense
uh
we learn in in physics textbook that the
time passes okay systems automatically
equilibrate because of the second law of
thermodynamics so they go toward
equilibrium
and when they go where they go to
equilibrium they go to a state which is
an equilibrium state and this
equilibrium state
is described
in the physics as one particular state
in the sense of
statistical mechanics a probability
distribution of all possible
configurations
okay
so the logic think of the logic time
passes
and this determines a particular state
now the idea
alain and i
uh
got independently is that maybe this is
the other way around
we're getting wrong
since in the fundamental theory there's
no preferred time but there are states
right there states because
because
we don't see the details of the world we
have an approximate description of the
world so we give a description of the
world which is a a a statistical state a
distribution of a possible configuration
now given a flow of time it
it
determines one particular distribution
maybe we should
view the other way around given
a probabilistic distribution of the
world what we know about the world
this determines the flow of time you can
mathematically compute it that way
from the
distribution you can do a simple and and
in our paper we wrote down this
mathematical passages
um
we
statistical state of the world produces
a type variable
and
this is the idea of terminal time and
anaconda pushed this father
because
if you have a quantum mechanical system
by necessity
you have some randomness because quantum
mechanics is randomness because if you
remember x and p
you you you don't commute and this no
commutativity implies some randomness
so one of the big big mathematical
results that alan khon has
obtained
is that
using this randomness
he could show
that any state
in the sense of quantum mechanical
states
determines a flow of time
and i don't want to enter into the
complication of const mathematics is for
neumann algebras complicated stuff
in some sense this evolution is unique
in some very peculiar senses evolution
is unique
so what khan is saying that
automatically once you have the
randomness of quantum mechanics you have
a time flow
the terminal time idea is a simpler
version of that it's just if you don't
know the details
your lack of knowledge of the details is
such that mathematics is sufficient to
pick up a specific time flow
okay
so uh you see if you study general
relativity
the question is uh
uh which one
of the variables do you want to call
time dockable
and the answer is well they all will
pre-order the same but
if you don't know the details and you
have a foggy version there's one which
is preferred
and let me give you
if i have one more minute on this
question kurt
a simple version of this story
um in special relativity
you have many time variables because if
you move uh
if you and i are moving with respect to
one another we have different lawrence
type in the lowest information there's t
and d prime different times right
they're all the same it's not one is
better than than another they're all the
same okay
but
suppose you have a cloud
which is hot they go out in the universe
and the cloud is hot
if it is hot
okay if you have a number of particles
that they move there's no preferred time
but if you have a hot cloud this is hot
and it has a temperature
which is determined by the fact that it
gots in equilibrium with itself
but it gots in equilibrium in one
lawrence frame not in all lawrence frame
it's it's an equilibrium in the frame in
which the
the cloud as a whole the center of mass
of the of the cloud is is is stationary
it's only in this frame that the
distribution is the distribution is the
the boltzmann distribution that you
expect
from the
so if you know the distribution if you
have a macroscopic description of that
you pick up a time a preferred lawrence
time
so you see
microscopically
you don't see any preferred time but
macroscopically is one preferred time
and the idea is that that's exactly what
happened in the world i mean we we live
in a world we interact with the world
macroscopically
obviously there is a past in the future
obviously there is a
a time direction
but that's because we use this
macroscopic variables if we were
really
interacting with all the degrees of
freedom at the level of generativity
all variables we will be equally
temporal variables
okay so let me see if i can understand
this now you can correct what i'm saying
time implies energy implies macrostate
as we talked about before
and then you can reverse that but then i
see that as a trade-off between
precision so if we were more precise we
wouldn't see time that's where alan
which i'm going to mispronounce but the
french mathematician you mentioned the
fields medalist alan conus that's elaine
konis that's where he comes in by saying
clearly you can never be extremely
precise anyway given quantum mechanics
so that's why
quantum mechanically you can just you
can induce time in that regard says that
correct okay correct exactly exactly so
let me stress that it's a beautiful idea
i love it
i think it's right but i'm not sure it's
a very speculative idea so i'm i i
people have been complaining about that
and it's i think it's an open question
what are their complaints to help us so
um
the complaint is that the main complaint
is that it's not
developed well enough because
[Music]
it
in an equilibrium situation
you need an equilibrium situation to
single out the time variable
uh but actually
what we really
what really
what we really do in our life when we
pick up a time variable is precisely
because it's not an equilibrium
situation the past is different from the
future
so in a sense it would be good to extend
this uh
terminal time outside this simple
equilibrium case in which past the
future the equilibrium we don't
distinguish anymore
um
uh past and future to to make this story
really completely coherent
now lisa mullen has a book on time as
well i don't recall the name of it if
you remember you can just say it
do you recall
uh
no i forgot i was talking about that
maybe the problem with time i don't know
because plenty of books called the
problem with at least in my head okay so
lee smallin has some views on time and i
recall him saying that it may be that
time is the most fundamental
now it might do firstly does that ring
true to you just that
okay great that's what lee thinks
prior to researching about
you carlo i was just thinking well lee
smulling and carla bervelli lupone to
gravity great let me start to research
the quantum gravity and i was thinking
that you pretty much agree with lee on
everything because in my head you both
were the same as the popularizers of
loop quantum gravity and developers of
it however as i read order of time i saw
there was a huge disconnect between you
and him on this level so do you mind
explaining what lee's views are on time
if you can and then where and why you
defer
yeah so uh let me start by saying that
lee and i
have been
i think we did the best uh physics uh
together my best physics and his best
physics probably together
um
all the
not just the beginning of flue quantum
gravity i mean the start of loop going
to gravity but also the the the
calculations of the egg values of the
area and the operator which are key
results in in quantum gravity and many
other things
um
so
uh
we we succeeded repeatedly collaborating
well and
we we
we have always remained very good
friends all through our life since since
our young age when we met
um so
he's i count him as a
one of my very very best friends and um
however in spite of that or maybe
precisely because of that
it's not true at all that we have been
agreeing
on ideas all the way through
in fact i would say even the opposite uh
we've been able to do physics together
precisely because we disagreed through
our disagreement interesting uh through
long discussions no no you're wrong no
you're wrong you don't see that yeah
so the beauty of the
our collaboration for me has been
being able to learn from one another
constantly being constantly challenged
by the other person
and uh and and through that getting to
to to to write down equations to do to
do calculations to put up theories and
to
to get results
um
lee also think this way and lee has a
very nice way of putting this story
which i love
once in an interview um
somebody asked him about the
disagreement with me and they thought
for a while and then said well look
if we had
had the same ideas
then one of the two of us would have
been superfluous
and i think it's a great idea right so
it's useless somebody who agrees with
you
on everything
so that's a that's the premise um now
uh
one of the biggest uh
disagreements uh
which has grown out
in in in the last decade is precisely
about time
uh it's not so strong as
uh
one might think uh because uh
there are a lot of uh
common
um
points that lee and i agree uh i mean i
i've been quoted often to say time does
not exist but
this is easily
that's a slogan slogans are
you know you can take it the way that
they want and it's easily misinterpreted
time does not exist does not mean that
we have to think about reality as just
static nothing happening
it's the other way around
i think that uh
um you know a static reality is time
passes nothing happened
but time passes and nothing happened
um
i think we have to think about reality
as a sequence of happenings
not a set of things
before we talked about things but if we
go into relativity into general
relativity what we actually describe in
the
it's always the evolution of things so
um even an object
the object we talked about the pen what
it really is in in my eyes at the light
of general activity it's a sequence of
processes there's something happening
it's happening now and then now and then
now and now and it's just pluses and
resemble one another and this is we call
the pen
and sorry so
to interject when you say happenings are
they the same as space-time events or is
that com is that different yeah yeah if
you want uh uh
an event it's something that is a it's a
it's just
limited in space and time and and
reality is this is a symbol of this okay
so uh
it's it's it's a symbol of events
where event means a region of space time
but also means a a something that is
happening in that regional space time in
fact
i think what the reason spray time is is
just happening right right whatever
happens in that region that's what the
regional space time is
and what happened is that there is a
field there is a gravitational field
there is electromagnetic field or
electrons whatever happens there
and if there are no electrons and no
uh electromagnetic field there is still
the gravitational field and if you take
away the electromagnetic field there's
nothing happening there's no that
reaches place time is not there
all right
so this hap this happening view of the
world is something lee is insisting a
lot and i also agree with him completely
100
we should talk about that this dynamical
aspect of all the processes not the
entities in isolation so that's the part
we agree
it's a big part
so all the people who talk about the
static four-dimensional universe
frozen time
um a block universe
i think it's misleading block universe
is just a you know a picture in our head
of an ensemble
of of events if i think of the story of
your life kurt
a block universe story of love lies
things happened okay it's a symbol of
happenings good
so it's the same for the universe
now where do lee and i disagree
we disagree about the origin of the
distinction within the past and the
future
that's the disagreement
lee
holds on to the idea
that the past and the future
intrinsically and profoundly different
at the sort of fundamental level
so these happenings are happening from
the
past to the future
something
the past exists fix it has happened it
is unchangeable the future is generally
open ah interesting okay that's a
disagreement i disagree with that i
think that uh
it seems to me that our best physics is
telling us
that this
very vivid difference between the past
and the future
is not in the grammar of neutrons
elementary grammar of nature it only
comes in
at the statistical thermodynamical level
when we have a
macroscopic description and therefore we
have entropy and therefore we have
things you know
ice melting down
uh and and and all the reversible
phenomena the all the irreversible
phenomena microscopic
the irreversibility uh
characterizes the microscopic variables
there's no irreversibility of the
microscopic variable
so the distinction between the past and
the future in my opinion
it's only for big things an electron
doesn't distinguish the past of the
future an atom does not distinguish the
past in the future a glass of water
with ice and water does distinguish
but the distinction is in the in the
picture
in the words
glass water and eyes it's a macroscopic
description so that's that's the point
where we disagree so we
you know the philosophical idea that
it's a
the description of the world is about
happenings and not about things not
about static
we're really on the same ground
but the
orientation of this happening is this
happening oriented in time from the past
to the future
is where we disagree i think that it
comes later on
at the fundamental level should forget
about that the the laws just don't
distinguish between the two
and lee thinks that in some sense the
laws distinguish between the two
so what does he say in response to
your justification for saying that it's
the blurriness that generates time or
the macroscopic states
what's his response
they say you be you you be you carlo
i
uh i'm not sure in fact next uh in in
next couple of weeks i'm going to
toronto and and and that's one thing i
want to talk with him i would say tell
me exactly what why do you think it's
all
i my reading but he might he might
disagree with my reading is that um
the intuition of the difference between
past and future for him is so strong
um so he's holding on to this romantic
idea of ex experiential time and wanting
to
i'm wanting to that's my forcing it down
okay so that's my reading right
that's my reading but you know he might
answer something else
okay what about janice sorry what about
julian barber the janice oh julian yeah
now i haven't had a chance to read his
book i started reading it but i don't
know what his theory is i think as far
as i got was just the history of
thermodynamics so what is the janus
point what is his theory on time and
then obviously compare and contrast with
yours
so a few coordinates here
first of all julian it's a fantastic
historian of science he wrote
a big thick scholarly book on the
history of mechanics which is a total
masterpiece in my opinion
um
then he uh
it's known for two ideas about time one
uh uh which is uh several
that's is mostly known for that
uh
some time ago um
his uh idea that we should think uh
at uh
at the world in a completely timeless
way just a distribution probability as
instantaneous
um
configurations
and recently he came out with a new idea
uh
which is this janus point
so uh i distinguish
three barbus
bubbles the bible's the historian of
physics and which you know chapel as the
uh french say i mean infinite uh respect
of him i learned so much from him
um barbara as the guy denying uh time in
the sense of uh
his old book on time and the third bible
which is about this childish point
so
the second one
i was never convinced much because here
complicated story about the universe
being extended in space but not in time
uh which i did not find convincing i i
we could go into that uh but this
we should not talk about that and we
should talk about the third one and the
third one this janus point idea uh it's
indeed uh um
quite uh um
intriguing
he's not the only one who has been
recently talking about sean carroll has
also
considered this idea there is there is
an increasing attention to this idea
and the idea is that
we are wrong
when we say that generically
if you take a system
generically most solutions of
integration of motion is in equilibrium
so there is no past and future
um
it's true that if you if you if you put
the gas in a box and you close it
with a fixed amount of energy
uh
most possible solutions or where the gas
goes in long time is in equilibrium and
in the equilibrium the entropy is
constant there's no past and future
so then we have to say why the entropy
was low in the past it seems strange
the point is that the universe is not
like a gas in a box that's the main
observation that also sounds like when
we were talking about that there are
some problems with applying our limited
scale physics or when we do experiments
to the universe as a whole i think
that's where i got it from was reading
the janus point he was saying the
universe is not a box so you can't apply
the same laws of thermodynamics to the
universe as a whole yes exactly so but
there's a specific very very specific
reason for which you cannot
that
there is no equilibrium state because
if you think about the imagine the
universe just a bunch of particles in an
infinite space okay they can spread
forever
okay so they never get to real
uh
to real equilibrium
so let's consider one possible
configuration okay
of this particle okay
a generic one they would just move
somehow maybe they come close at some
point and then they disperse
so if you look at the future they
disperse if you come back there's some
moment in which they're closer and then
they disperse again
so the entropy in that configuration
okay
it's up goes to a minimum and then grows
of course there's no preferred direction
of time because you know both directions
disperse
but there's a minimum
so if you're on one side the entropy is
growing like that if you're on the other
side
like that so we just have one side and
of course the entropy is growing right
if think a mountain
any mountains it has you know one
direction which is down and the other
direction which is up so generically
there's always one direction down one
direction up
so the idea is well maybe we got
confused about the model of the gas in
the box and the equilibrium forget the
equilibrium maybe the right way is
thinking that generically uh
histories possible history of the world
uh
evolved in some way and necessarily
there is one point which is minimal
entropy and then it goes one side and
the other this is the core updating
maybe i'm oversimplifying it a little
bit but that's a coral idea
so um
there are some
questions about that there are some
possible doubts i'm not sure is
it's really a solution of the
of of the end of of which problem or the
problem why the entropy is low in the
past
this you know
why the time is oriented because in the
in the past it was low entropy so why in
the past of the slow entropy
that's an attempt to answer that
question
there is something ringing very
interesting and i think there's a
discussion going on right now
among theoretical physicists and
philosophers
uh on
should we buy this argument is it
correct um i'm interested in the
discussion
and i i hope that in some years it will
clean up
namely yes that's a good way of of
thinking
about uh why entropy was low in the past
one direction which is the one we call
the past
uh or
uh no come on we're getting confused
about probabilities here
you're it's you're super tissually
squeezing in some some
some some intuition which is not correct
i i don't know it's a it's it's um
it's
relatively recent
that
we've been thinking about that
and uh i'm i'm open to to this idea i
found it interesting
this minimum point does he say that's
the big bang or does the big bang happen
at somewhere on the up so it's still
relatively yeah in a sense that in a
sense that's what's called the janus
point because genesis is god
in in rome it's it's latin god
um which is the god of the doors of the
of the change of the year it has two two
faces it was always
represented with a head with two faces
one face is this way one face is the
other way so the janus point is the
point where the future you know the one
future this way one future that way
because uh
the future is determined by end to the
glowing so this is the minimum of the
entropy so entropy goes this way and it
goes this way so whoever is here or
whenever you are here you see the future
this way whenever here you see the
future this way so you always see the
right the big bang in the past right
that's what you call the best yeah
interesting interesting okay now to
wolfram
which we can take out so don't worry
do you have any
thoughts on wolfram's model critiques
any
what do you find interesting when you
find out interesting convincing not
convincing
um
i
i am not uh
overexcited
by the idea that a simple classical
um
microscopical model
could
you reproduce
the
the complexity of the physics that
that that we see uh why do you call it a
classical model
because it's definite the hypergraph is
definite or what
uh it's classically in the sense that uh
uh you can view this as evolution in
time and at
each specific steps moment there are
there are steps uh the fundamental
variables which have a
a unique value so in that sense
is classical quantum mechanics
variables don't don't have a specific
value
um
i think that to
from here
to reconstruct the complexity of quantum
mechanics in full
has not been done yet i have not seen it
uh yet
and uh i i i doubt that one could
actually
uh do it unless i see it in in detail
there are aspects of quantum mechanics
um
like those uh captured by uh coconut
spectre theorem
uh
or by the bell inequalities
which are very hard to reproduce this
way notoriously very hard to reproduce
this way so um
one might copy some aspect of quantum
mechanics
uh
i i haven't seen
the full prediction of quantum mechanics
coming out
yet what about for general relativity i
don't know if you've heard the claims or
read the paper
that the hypergraph model can reproduce
and you can tell me yeah just so you
know my naive assessment
i believe what they do is an adm
decomposition at some point and so
whenever i hear that
it to me okay so you're foliating so
then you have a preferred time and for
some reason that
i'm averse to that because space time to
me shouldn't be able to at least
generically it's not able to be foliated
but i don't know if that's if that's
just my own personal taste and i should
or if that's an actual argument against
or for it okay this is your personal
taste
but it's also my personal personal taste
but it's not an argument because
if it was possible to derive
uh all the
all of the theory
from a completely different point of
view namely not the point of view of
general covariance not the point of view
of einstein but from the point of view
of
existing or special preferred foliation
then okay we would have to confront that
but once again
um
there's some aspect of generativity
which
has been recovered
well
i i i tried to read some of the papers
over the copy of general relativity
um you know
it's
if you're something
geometrical and you go at large scale uh
generativity it's uh
come up it's not too hard to
uh to come out with uh uh with the icing
equations
uh
but once again this is not full
generativity uh yet and if it is food
generativity it would predict definitely
corrections to generativity
uh
which
we would be testable
okay
so until i see
this testing namely that generativity is
factually wrong on some short scale
and and we see the discrepancy
um
i would say well this is a
more complicated way of saying the same
story which it's distinguishable
and it's based on different principles
which are not the ones which seem to be
implementing the world namely in the
world it seems to be that it's another
reference frame as you say there is no
preferred for
foliation as you say so that's the kind
of things we have learned from
generativity so why do we have to give
them up
um
you know let's go to copernicus once
again after copernicus um
did his model it it seemed to work very
well on something one thing it did work
very well is that if you if you make the
other planets go around the sun
uh you understand why
uh the the other planets have a feature
of the emotion which have a period of
one year
because they go around the sun so of
course they were
but the
strongly counter-intuitive things was
the earth's move
so
some people in particular tico bry the
greatest astronomer uh
that uh you know kepler used his data
for for doing his work
ticklebride came out with a system which
is called the ticonic system the system
of t cobra which was intermediate
between um copernicus and uh
america uh and ptolemy which was that
the earth is the center of the universe
the earth is fixed so there's nothing
counterintuitive the sun goes around
and all the other problems go around the
sun yeah it's brilliant idea if you want
right okay you get the
the cake and and you eat it too so you
get advantage of copernicus without the
concept of difficulty of copernicus
so in a sense it was to try to recover
the advantage of copernican staying with
the old
mind frame which is the earth is fixed
okay
is it coherent yes it's clearance has it
been historically useful no
i mean we would have never got to newton
or kepler or galileo and and modern
physics was that way
the point about capital was precisely
that if we give up this moving if we get
out of this
mind frame
of we are static
we have a better way of understanding
the world
so tico was completely wrong
scientifically and of course we
recognize it completely wrong
scientifically right
so i think that when we have learned
general relativity or when we learn
special relativity of course we can you
know by being
super smart like tico arrange thing that
we stay with the old conceptual thing
and you recover the same thing with some
some technicalities
but we don't learn more about the world
we just hang on yourself to
all thinking and don't accept the new
thinking which is the one that
allows to go faster the new thinking is
move forget it
forget this intuition that my ground is
not moving
so it's the same with this
reconstruction quantum mechanics for
underlying basically classical system i
don't believe that it's impossible i
haven't seen it yet but i
suppose it's possible
but
is it do we believe that this
pushing them ahead is telling us that
really really nature
in its the death it's like we thought
yesterday
come on nature it is death it's like we
think today not like we thought yes
there's moves
is this what you
in your mind in the back your mind
perhaps think of lee smolin's idea of
time like lee you are trying to hold on
yeah it's the same story it's exactly
the same story
so take the take the discovery seriously
right what einstein did
when he did special relativity
there were this maxwell equations
um
that seemed to contradict
galilean relativity
uh
which one is wrong
einstein
answer is neither
they're both right believe the physics
right
uh and and and when i said the general
activity he took this idea of maxwell
the fields
and he applied to to gravity so he
believed the physics believe the new
results that work those are empirically
con
don't believe your intuition believe
that it works
what if sean carroll who is a proponent
of the many world says to you carlo
you're trying to hold you say that the
many worlds is distasteful because look
the cost yeah but you're calling it a
cost because you're trying to hold on to
something else so what if sean says that
to you
um
i i am in a discussion with with sean on
on
on another thing he
not only
uh take the many world
interpretations seriously he likes it
but he likes a particularly radical
version
of the um
of the latino many volunteers if it's
not radical enough already right
he yeah he he called it the mag dog he
called it the mad dog
uh
many world interpretation the mad dog
in which there is only hilbert space and
state and hamiltonian nothing else so
you want to extract everything from
from that
uh i'm i'm
i i'm debating that i i think it's not
going to work in general activity for
this and that reason i mean he has he
has an answer which is yeah you know
you have this terminal time i can use
your term of time to make it answer so
he's trying to use my own ideas against
myself
um
uh what would he say uh to me well i
think that there is a he belongs to a
um
a group of physicists
that are very much in love with many
world because they find it very simple
and and straightforward it's just this
wave function
and out of this wave function we can
extract
um
we can extract the rest so um
i i never heard
him
um
telling me what he thinking the
relational interpretation is is wrong
because when we when we've talked with
um we talked about his ideas uh
especially his this mad dog version of
of evelette and i i sort of uh tried to
point out what what are the the the
technical limitations of this um
of this idea
um
there is some people who learned quantum
mechanics
starting from schrodinger
and can only think about quantum
mechanics in terms of the wave function
the
quantum mechanic was not born with
schrodinger was born with heisenberg and
max borgnon
and
the the gottingen
people in matrix mechanics before
schrodinger paulie dirac
uh and it can be thought without any
wave function without any uh
any state
and i think that by introducing the
uh the wave function
should even confuse things made
calculation easier but confused the
ontology the picture so everybody
started thinking about this wave and
got confused
um
i think that
sean is definitely not making the
mistake of
holding on to classical intuition
to the opposite i mean he he takes the
the schrodinger wave function very
seriously tried to build everything
from that so he's blaming me probably uh
what
i am blaming
wolfram and lee
namely that i want to stay attached to
classical
to variables having values describing
the world in terms of facts um
that's probably what he
he wanted to
he would like to blame me
my answer is that uh
i think it doesn't work to think that
the world is just a way function is the
way he would like to he would like to
say the way function nothing else
there's this vector in hilbert space and
nothing else
and i think that uh
vector input spaces don't give me pens
don't give me
books don't give me the concrete
description of the world to
to to have a quantum theory you need
much more
many ingredients
uh
so it's not clean the pure wave function
picture of the world um you need the
operators you need again values you need
again vectors you need this structure
and this structure he hopes to just take
it out from the hamiltonian
uh
but once again i have not
seen it happening uh
yet so i think that the
um
this way of thinking about quantum
mechanics is not going to be
fruitful we need the algebra observance
quantum mechanics about
non-communication no computer variables
the core of quantum mechanics is p q
minus q p equal i h bar
this is the core
of of quantum mechanics variables don't
commute like an unknown would insist
upon is a discovery that the variables
we use to describe the world
are not always defined because they are
no commuting so they cannot be both
defined at the same time that's core
not the wave function now how is he
throwing that out by trying to put so
much emphasis on the wave function how
is he throwing out those non-commuting
operators oh that's the mag
the mother dog interpretation there are
no
no
no
no
at the fundamental level there's only
the wave function and then he says
there's
hamiltonian the amazonia has some
structure
in it and from the structure of the
hamiltonian
one can
okay derive from the structure of the
comet the composition of hilbert spaces
in
subsystems
and is some system from the subsystem i
can extract something which corresponds
to the algebra of observables so it's a
very indirect way of trying to
extract it from the dynamics it's the
dynamics that
should give us the valuables
it's a long way to go
is there a reason that he's starting
he's saying that there let's imagine the
wave function of the universe seeing
quantum field theory and i'm not saying
anything you don't know it
it's like operator value it's not that
people say it's field but it's like a
strange field it's an operator valued
field because it's not exactly what yeah
the mystics say it's like all like water
and waves well it's like an operator
wave if you want to call that so why is
he not using why is he going why is he
going to qm and our q of t
in other words
like the wave function of q no no no he
has in mind
quantum field theory he has my qft but
but but this particular structure that
defined qft
he would
like to say that he's only written in
the hamiltonian
uh so he would not he would say that you
know fundamentally of the world is not
qft is it's a very rich structure as you
say there are these quantum fields which
are actually operated this is local
quantum operators it's a field of
operators
uh which commute don't commute have this
all this problem so you have to give all
this machinery to make it work
and this machinery the operators the
fields are observable so what we
interact describe how we interact with
the field right
uh he wants to discard all that
he want to say there's only
a big guild of space a hub space is just
a great thing we don't require anything
else
okay
and it's just how the
what gives the motion
of of of of the state in the hill this
place
but he will say the hamiltonian has some
structure inside it because it we can
it's eigen values have some structure
some some some way of combining them and
we secretly know
about all the machinery of quantum field
theory
uh it's it's a technical step i don't
know if i if if i need to go into that
um
but but but he has in mind quantitative
theory in fact the the property of the
hamiltonian that
he uses is the locality of the
interaction tony can be written as a
uh
and the locality gives the region of
space
uh
so here's this
this extreme everything or extreme uh
many world
and my objection
is you need a hamiltonian and you don't
have an eternal generativity because
there's no time
okay now what is your opinion on eric
weinstein's geometric unity have you had
a chance to go through any of the papers
no
no i should i'm sorry i i should but i
don't i i i could not follow my opinion
okay that's fine how about
donald hoffman's have you do you know
donald hoffman
so he has
the case against reality and yours is
called reality is not what it seems
yes oh this is a big philosophical
discussion um
he definitely have
um
a number of very good points
um
and some
radical conclusions from
from those
um
i i know about a little bit about his
ideas but i have not read his book so
i'm not sure i have a
good uh gauging of exactly what you want
to draw
from that
um
but let me let me say the core of of
what i think um
we
interact
with the external world around us
through um our senses and to our uh um
the way the brain
interprets
um
what we see around us
and uh
i think it's
uh
a a very good and and very deep
observation to
recognize to realize that we call what
we call the objects
around us
are to a large extent uh
mental constructs
um
that uh
our brain
uh puts together
uh
on the basis of how
useful
uh
this construct have been in our
evolution to to
um to allow us to to survive
so
uh
in in
in a sense we're we're seeing a movie of
what is outside which is vaguely related
to what is outside whatever it's
happening outside
and is deeply um
colored by our reading of it um
this is uh this is an observation which
has been made in philosophy uh
many times in fact it's one of the main
uh things for which kant
is known
and kant is considered a major
philosopher in
the western tradition but
it's it's others others before and after
have
have made this observation
and i think it's important uh because
what we're describing at every level is
not the world it's a world of
perspective it's a world aspect
um
and i think this this has to be deeply
into your eyes even if it seems so what
what has the natural reaction of that i
mean there's a chair there and of course
i mean i am saying well come on the
chair is there independently for me and
there is a sense in which this is not
true
the chair is my particular reading of
what is going on for a number of reasons
for a
variety of reasons that he he goes in
details in the very right
so the disagreement is
now so far i'm i'm completely with him
uh
now the two points
one is that all right so
what
um
then what
um
and there are two points i would uh not
really object but i would
say how i think about this first of all
that this does not mean
that our mental world
is more
solid and known that the external
because exactly the same arguments
uh employed here for the external world
exactly the same arguments work for our
mental world namely
there is nothing certain either
in what we see as our sense of our self
our perception these are also
complicated the
uh
cultural biological construction
that our representation of the world
has so our reputation for the world
include a notion of myself and also my
representations also my representations
which are all notions that were
developed culturally
so the same criticism
against the existence of outside objects
i think hold
for the existence of
the self
uh and my mental world
okay
so this leaves us where
i think and this is my my arrival point
this leaves us in my opinion
towards
the anti-foundationalism
that we talked at the beginning of the
story
namely we should not ask the wrong
question the wrong question is what is
really really really outside there
that's a wrong question
the right question
is
um
[Music]
i see
a mirror
okay
it seems to me that a chair is the other
side of the mirror
is it true or false no it's false is an
illusion the chair is not the other side
of the mirror the chair is here
okay
the chair is really here and falsely
outside the mirror that's correct
okay
we can play this game step by step
by realizing that things are not like
that we're misunderstanding there
there's a better way of understanding
that they're not like that the
misunderstanding there's a matter with
if we ask the question okay so what is
the ultimate reality
independently
of any representation that's not a good
question in my opinion
that's a wrong question reality is that
chair reality is that son the reality is
that sharing the mural
and their relations their relative
relations
so i will jump out of this discussion
okay and
distinguish if you want the apparent
reality and the ultimate reality and
forget about the ultimate reality we are
talking about this after reality and
that's what we call reality
reality is the ensemble
of this phenomena of which i am part and
your part and the cherries part
and all the way we
understand better and better and better
we can say they are made by atoms for
fantastic we can say the atoms are a
quantum mechanical object that interact
with us fantastic we we get more and
more
complexity of the phenomena
but we
if we get if we ask the question
where do we ground all that what is the
ultimate reality forget about this so if
the case against reality
that he's making
is the case is the case against the idea
of an ultimate reality out there
and in favor of an ultimate reality for
our
impressions i disagree
because there is a good way of
understanding our impression as caused
by the chair that chair
not
a metaphysical chair
or if you want in kantian terms who
cares about the aluminum we care about
the phenomena
what we call reality is a phenomena not
an
hypothetical thing
behind the phenomena
that's my take on it
when i hear that well here's what i'm
thinking okay you said the chair is not
really behind the mirror it's really
over to the left of me okay yeah
and that's what it means really
right we have this notion of really we
have this notion of reality then if i
was to get you or anyone else just say
people in general to what are some facts
that of what is a part of reality see
we're trying to derive a definition from
looking at well i say that this
microphone is really in front of me and
then i may point to other objects
and say that really is the case but then
well what if there's an inconsistency in
what we call a part of our reality and
not then which one do we take as more
why do we favor this microphone being
really in front of me but
santa claus not really existing no you
have you have i got exactly the point i
think we have to use really
coherence just which ones mix cohere
together consistent what is it
i i think we have to realize that uh
really in reality
it's uh uh it can be used in different
uh right right right do use at different
levels and it's fine we do different
levels for instance um
did
uh um hamlet
really killed his uncle
yes he did really kill his uncle i mean
um if you tell me you know hamlet did
not kill his uncle at the end of the
play i said no no he did he really did
look i come with shakespeare texts i
said it's written here i'm killing you
uncle okay
so i'm using really
okay
okay it's it's real
and now you tell me come on it's not
real because it's a play of course it's
not real
okay
so when am i right when i say i'm real
what i'm saying unboxed right in both
cases i'm just meaning two different
views so real is in a context
if you want to take a real outside the
questions what is really really really
real
behind all the context
that has no meaning
so talking about the mirror we make a
distinction between the chair and the
other side of the mirror and the chair
that chair there
and
that distinction it's meaningful and we
correctly use one to be real and one not
to be real and i can argue exactly what
i mean i i mean if i walk against the
mirror i just
hit my nose against them
while if i walk there that chair i can
see down i mean just
there's a very precise sense in which
one is more real than the other
okay and in the in if i'm dreaming
there's a very precise sense in which i
say that's not real it was a dream
okay
but within the dream itself there i
think which are real in the dream and
not real in the dream okay in the dream
i can dream of somebody who is telling
me uh i mean look you thought that is so
bad is not so they reveal something else
so within the dream there is a notion of
reality there in the movie there is a
notion of reality there
so
the question what is real is a very
slippery question it's a
context by context it makes sense
but every time we see a context
in which
we're giving something for granted and
we're building them
and when
when i hear the argument
um
look
uh
the
the way my brain
makes sense of that chair it's because
in my brain there is a notion of sitting
there is an ocean because there is a
space of colors blah blah blah blah
and
therefore uh the chair it's it's it's
it's it's really a cherry
in an illusion for me
the context is a context in which i'm
giving for real a number of things my
brain
the the the the the more the the the the
the the existence of light coming to me
you you're creating a context so that
within that context there's a notion of
reality and and and and illusion
and what about that context itself is it
real is not real
it's
i i think that we describe the phenomena
that we interact with
and within description that's the
scripture is reality that's what we mean
by reality
and if we try to say
uh
beyond the phenomena
what is the true ultimate reality we're
making a mistake
and this is a mistake
that a lot of philosophers
have warned us against many
hume kant um
a lot of phenomenal say careful
i mean you take a distinction
the chair in the mirror and and the
chair you see there and you're trying to
replay that
that's everything you know about the
universe and something else which is a
real real real thing that's a real real
thing forget about it don't don't do
that
so i would say
that
we don't have a case against reality
with a case for reality
and against the idea that there's an
ultimate reality behind it beyond
everything
when you say that what i'm wondering is
is that because we can never know what's
outside of what's knowable so you gave
kant the phenomenon the pneumonia give
that example is it because of that we
can just not know it why is it that
it's so foolish to talk about the
foundational reality
uh
to the extent in which we can know
something else we may hope to know
something else we we correctly
put this question
uh on the table
right
uh but only to the extent in which we
may have a hope
to know something else
um
i'll explain my reasoning behind the
question and me so when i'm speaking to
some non-dualist i don't know if you
know what non-dualism is
they would say consciousness is primary
and then i pose the question well how do
you know what if there's something
outside consciousness a simple question
they would say yeah but you could never
know that
well
it's true i can't experience what's
outside my experience by definition
but that to me doesn't mean that it
doesn't exist now you one can say that
it's foolish to talk about it because it
never interacts with you and you have no
clue that's another argument but to say
it doesn't exist
because it's outside of our experience i
don't find that particularly convincing
so that's what's behind my question
no no it's it's it's it's a good
question uh i i i see the point
um
we
what is the use
of
of imagining
that there is something beyond our
knowledge
okay i think there are two uses
one is that
because perhaps we may get to know it
and
the other is just you know to recognize
that
who knows it might be or that might not
be something
and
these are two very different situations
uh
namely uh
if if i see a chair and i suspect that
it might be in understandable in terms
of atoms
i can
ask the question uh
maybe beyond the appearance of the chair
there is a atomic structure
and then i can do some science or i can
do some investigation or can do b
boltzmann and come up with explanation
of temperature on the basis of that
or be einstein and come up with a brown
emotion and from the atoms explained by
an emotion or then you know be ibm that
make a microscope and see the atoms
so
beyond some appearances i suspected that
there was some reality
a better deeper
um description reality and that allowed
me to get a better escape from the world
that's
it's a situation in which is good to say
well
maybe i just don't know something which
i might know it
but if the argument
uh
like the case against reality is that
there is a reality which is in principle
unknowable
that they cannot know about that
which is a completely different story is
to say
maybe there is an aspect of
beyond what we call reality usually
which is
in principle and accessible
and then what interest do we have on
that on that
i mean why should we talk about that
i mean suppose uh you know i come to you
and say you know i believe that this is
a universe but there's a next to another
direct dimension where there are you
know green dragons going around and
speaking chinese to one another okay but
they never interact with us we never
interact with them
and uh
and they just totally
and then you say how do you know about
that i mean i don't but can you disprove
it no i cannot disprove it but what's
the interest of this story zero
so i think that ultimate reality is like
the dragons
speaking chinese to one another and
playing football in another dimension
should not talk about
by reality we mean what we interact with
with the complexity
of the different layers
and we may find other layers
perfectly but we shouldn't worry about
this
not being the totality of things
because that's the totality of things
we're interested about
here's what i think of when i hear that
again the word pragmatism comes up
because you're talking about well what's
the use of it what's the point of it
so then i'm wondering well is
is reality or theorizing tied to
pragmatism in some sense yes because
we're finite beings we have to choose to
do something but then
can we not philosophize for the sake of
philosophizing so that's what occurs to
me and then at the same time when saying
well we don't know if these chinese
dragons are playing football in some
other dimension that never interacts
with us
however i would say it's still firstly
it's fun to think about chinese football
playing dragons and second
just like we were talking about in the
beginning
scientists have an aversion or generally
now contemporary scientists have an
aversion to philosophizing
they would say well this is much of what
you're talking about especially when it
comes to metaphysics is unfalsifiable
science is a methodology let's apply
that let's stick to our mathematics but
then you were making the great argument
which is
that leads us to plenty of places even
if it seems misleading at first or even
if it seems to not interact with us
first
so that's what else i think about it is
that okay even if we say there are these
non-interacting
chinese
dragons that play football
okay let me hear you out do you truly
believe that do you have some
great arguments for it let's hear it
okay let's think about that would this
be the case of that and then you can
arrive someplace interesting so i'd say
first you said it's about a point what
is the point what is the use then i say
well that's pragmatist that's pragmatism
in this sense of it has to have a use to
us and i'm saying well we could talk
about that but then also at the same
time there could be a use in the sense
that well we can talk about
incomprehensible unfalsifiable notions
and still lead us somewhere propitious
in the long run okay so that's what i
think now i say that and i'm curious
what are your thoughts on what i've just
said
well i i wouldn't not disagree with you
um
i think there is a
tradition in philosophy
so let me develop something i hinted
before there's a tradition in philosophy
which is to warn
philosophy as a cure witkinstein is a
master of that cure against wrong
questions
we're wrong what does wrong mean here
uh you probably call me a pragmatist if
you say wrong means useless um
so
uh
like not good for us ultimately leads us
astray but as humans
um
yeah so just take us to the wrong
to to the wrong
if if you stay in science science was
often liberated
uh by philosophical thinking that
science often made step ahead
by getting input from philosophy that
said well you don't you don't have to
ask this question um
certainly
this played around
copernicus but played a bigger role in
einstein einstein got from mark the idea
that
uh
the asking the question of uh uh what
it's really really meaning of two things
happening at the same time it's just a
wrong question we forget about that
that's not
meaningful i mean
and
also from mac heisenberg
took the idea that
the election doesn't have a position at
any time
directly from this is a this is a wrong
you you you're imposing a
so there is a there's a tradition in
philosophy which is warning
against the wrong kind of questions and
uh
i think what i'm saying here what i'm
trying to say here is that uh
um
it's uh
the notion of reality is good uh because
we we use it to distinguish the the
chair in the mirror from the chair
um
on which i can see it to distinguish the
dream from the
from what i see when i'm awake for
disclaiming what is uh what's in a play
or in a novel from what is not in a play
in a novel
if you
or or for distinguished i mean you tell
me that yesterday you met
john and say is that real or false
you lie that's this is meaningful this
is uh we know exactly what you mean by
real and false here
um
but then if we take this notion of real
and we make it uh uh
extrapolated
to say everything we see is not real
uh
because everything we see
uh
has a level of illusion of some kind
much weaker kind of the mirror much
weaker kind
uh
it's good that we realize that there's a
level of illusion but then we are
postulating that there is a
underlying reality
behind that
and that postulation might be
wrong
simply wrong or at least it's let's put
it this way it's remarkable that science
failed to get to that ultimate reality
so far so why should we expect it wait
what is the multiple reality i mean
quantum fields i mean we don't even
know exactly what is a quantum field
because of the complication of quantum
mechanics we know it's a classical field
um
quantum field is something that
manifests itself with particles
okay but particles are not real
so we are confused on the ultimate
reality even in contemporary physics
um
in contemporary physics uh today
uh
not to mention about in philosophy in
general what is ultimate reality matter
energy god spirits language
everybody came out with a with an
ultimate reality story and and failed to
convince the others
um
so
the perspective i find it
interesting is to de-emphasize
the notion of ultimate reality
and interesting interesting interesting
and use the word reality at level by
level i mean there's
surreal that there's a chair there but
he's also real that that chair is as
some illusory thing it's also real
there's just a bunch of atoms both
things are true
and within each context something is
real something is it's also and we can
add context at
levels in which is a better
understanding of reality
uh without getting trapped into oh my
god we don't have access to reality we
do have access to reality that's the
chat
okay i'll explain my thoughts what
occurs to me and then we can get the
rapid fire questions and answers just
from the audience because you've been so
generous with your time thank you
is that cool
absolutely okay
this has been a very philosophical
uh take little physics little loop
quantum gravity lipocrypt this is very
very good
i guess
basic philosophy of science and physics
understanding and
the nature of reality
let me recapitulate what you said so i
make sure that we're on the same page
there are different ways that we use the
word reality just like there are
different ways we use the word time and
just like there are different ways we
use the word almost any noun essentially
depending on the context so let's
imagine we can put these contexts in
separate boxes much of the confusion
occurs when we think
well we
mean
well much of much of miscommunication is
we intend it to be from box a but you
perceive it as from being from box b so
the contexts are mixed up
and what i was wondering is when it
comes to reality even within the same
context
i don't see there being an internally
consistent even within the context and
by the way you mentioned wittgenstein
wittgenstein had this notion of language
games i believe the language games would
be the equivalent of
context here boxes
i'm wondering if there's an internally
in an internally consistent notion of
reality
okay so
well
and then where was i going with that ah
ah okay now my
what i think is at least i haven't seen
any and any time i try to come up with
well i haven't seen any internally
consistent definition of reality
now there are a couple answers to that
one is
the donald hoffman method
forget it so it's there's no reality
it's all unreal in some sense then
there's the phenomenological answer the
phenomenology answer which is actually
all you experience is real it's real to
you even if you're schizophrenic and you
see a snake in front of you that's real
to you
but then you actually took a different
route which i never occurred which is
please stop using the word reality just
let's forget about it so am i making a
correct summary and if i'm in yeah just
correct yes yes yes yes yes uh please
stop uh using the word reality uh
unlabeled and
uh
divorce the context reality i mean use
use the word reality in each context
so
it's like we should have reality sub a
reality sub b and make sure that we're
in
in this movie this is real this is real
this is false
but that's a movie it's all false in in
a different sense of real so the the
the
realize
there's a variety of meaning with in the
context in which you
uh
in which you you use it so in a context
we
give you context and i
i give you a much better definition of
reality okay
in the context of the miserable written
by victor lugo i can absolutely
uniquely see what is real and what is
not real what is real is what is written
in the book it's not real it's what you
add it's not written the book okay in
the context of the history of the united
states
it's absolutely real
maybe
when we can make a mistake but we know
that to make a mistake so we know what
is real was not real that you know
george washington
announces becoming a king whatever uh
whatever happens
um
so
context by context we have a
with a clean notion of of reality which
allows us to make distinction
um
[Music]
between real things and not real things
it's a unique
word real reality to reality real not
real outside all context
which i think is dangerous
all right yeah so fast yep yep the
information paradox you said it's like
falling in love with holography and that
the entropy inside a black hole can be
different than the outside so can you
explain what you mean by
that yes um
right now in the uh
community of physicists
uh there have been a a
separation between two communities which
have completely different opinions
about the
black hole paradox
one community it's convinced that
there's a problem
the problem it's
before quantum gravity so before the end
of the evaporation
and the problem is due to the fact that
the black hole shrinks and people are
convinced
that the number of states of the black
hole
um it's bound by the area
by the pakistan um
hawking entropy
and therefore uh the problem is that the
state outside seems to be um
thermal
and uh
in pure state and
for that to be possible to save
unitarity
uh information should be somewhere
and the only place we could be
reasonably inside the black hole but
there are not enough states inside the
black hole
because of
horizon has shrunk
and this has
created a huge a huge problem
and
there are
complicated solutions which have been
studied today and people are sort of
getting convinced that this complicated
solution of the the way out
the other half of the community
which are most relativist and not
particle physics and people like me
um uh
don't just don't believe this story
absolutely because to create this
paradox you have to believe quantum
mechanics which is unitarian we all
expect quantum mechanics to be unity you
have to believe uh
uh
that uh
generativity holds and some
reasons we don't expect one to gravity
and
many of us expect that and you have to
believe
an additional assumption
which is the number of black holes
states inside the black hole it's bound
by the area
and that
has no strong ground
people got in love with the idea
because there are calculations that
allow you to describe black hole in
terms of a final number of states bound
by the area but this is a description
uh
of what you see from the outside
as long as the horizon is an event
horizon it's horizon forever
and the horizon black hole is not an
eventualizer because at some point the
black hole becomes very small something
happens
and at that point it may very well be
that the big information which is
outside comes out
okay
and the confusion the subtle confusion
here
it's that
people
is used to say
that the phenomenon entropy is bounded
by the thermodynamical entropy namely
phenomena entropy is in
the the the
the amount of information due to the
entanglement between the inside the two
things
at the terminal entropy
count the number of state if you
interact terminally with something and
people say well of course for neumann
entropy it's bounded by the
thermodynamical entropy because the
thermodynamic entropy count the number
you'll see it if you don't have this
state you cannot have fun
phenomena
but that's wrong
because uh
if one part of of the interior system
is thermally disconnected you can still
have a big volume and entropy
and a decreasing thermodynamical entropy
and that's exactly what happened in
black holes
and
people who are sort of blinded by
over excessive
taking a strong version of holography
just don't see that very basic
point
and don't see that if you give a full
description
that include what happened after the end
of evaporation you can have a phenomenon
to be much larger than the thermodynamic
enterprise simply talking the whole of
the black hole shrinks becomes smaller
and smaller and smaller
where the backhoe evaporates
but the inside remains very big there's
a lot of information there
which is not lost
where the black hole ends the
evaporation when you say the inside
remember slowly comes out the inside of
yeah
the black hole
the black hole has a it's like a throat
yep the horizon and then there is an
inside which is very very big that's the
point i mean you can have a
very very big spatial
space like surfaces are huge
okay and that's where the information is
and at the end of evaporation now we're
in quantum gravity and with loop quantum
gravity you can do calculations to what
happened
and you there's there's a quantum
transition to a region in which the
inside is still there and slowly it
leaks out all the information
so i think that there's a
perfectly
coherent picture
which shows that it's not true
that is a black hole information problem
the belief in the black hole information
problem
is based on a
a dogma
uh has become a dogma which is not
supported by by anything
that the
uh the number of states of black hole
computer from the outside also include
the information inside
in popular science you always hear that
when someone falls into the black hole
you won't see them
well you'll see them freeze right at the
horizon
and there you'll see their watch frozen
too now if the black hole event yeah
yeah
this is
we don't know that because that's the
benefit of gravity see that's that's
exactly the that's exactly the problem
uh
when time goes on
okay you see what you see somebody is
crossing the black hole
so the person crossing black hole of
course crosses it like oh i mean nothing
particular happened crossing the horizon
just normal
normal time going back
but the light rays that it emits
uh gets to you
later and later and later and later okay
now if the horizon is an eventerizer so
if the horizon stays there forever yeah
you can go to infinity and you only see
the person before crossing
but we don't know in fact the the rise
is not an element right the rise does
not go to infinity because at some point
the black hole becomes plunkin and
that's where in quantum gravity and when
in quantum gravity there is a quantum
transition
after which
the information outside can go outside
okay so if you wait long enough
you see inside the black hole
interesting that's the point
interesting okay next one do you find
that your ability to learn let's say
math and physics has increased with age
or decreased
decreased decreased much decreased i uh
when i was in my 20s i could take a
complicated mathematically complicated
paper just sit down on a chair and
read it through and i would get
everything easily
and then it slowly became more
complicated and now in my 60s i struggle
i go slow i read less papers so my
capacity to learn is decreasing
and also
i think my flexibility
of thinking is going down i tend to know
much more things before i have much more
developed views
before i know more things
i see when other people are wrong
because i know things they don't know
it's happened much more often than
before i mean it's easy to see the
mistakes of the others because because i
know more things everybody getting
colder no small things
so that's why all the people why is it
but also
i'm more stupid because i'm more trapped
in my own thinking i have more
difficulty of coming out from my own
thinking
what would you have done differently in
the development of your theory it could
be as simple as i would have spent more
time going for walks with lee than
sitting down or i would have spent more
time thinking about
about holography like ads cfd
correspondence for whatever reason or
you would have spent less time arguing
with your like what is it that you would
have done differently in the development
of your current theories
um
there have been situations in which
people have raised objections
to things i've done
i got convinced that these objections
were wrong
and i just ignored
that and just
don't didn't bother respond
and
i
i don't think i should have paid more
attention to the objections because i
did always pay very much attention to
the objections that i read about
but i think it was a mistake not to
respond and not to immediately sit down
and try to argue in detail
um
i
i probably overestimated myself and uh
and in the field as a whole
thinking oh come on i think that's wrong
and people will figure out by themselves
i
i try not to engage in debates
and uh and discussions
um
and and go my own way and something
sometimes works very well
but sometimes has
you know created long misunderstanding
so i should have
more engaged with with criticism trying
to respond and be more
more
more more
part of the group and just debating with
the group
okay this question comes from stefan
alexander he's a professor of
theoretical physics and i know he's a
great guy great great he's the writer of
fear of black universe fear of a black
universe and the link to that is in the
description also i'll be speaking with
stefan so that's either out or
coming up how does time play into
quantum gravity
you've mentioned it plays into quantum
mechanics does it play into quantum
gravity per se
um
it does not
i think that's uh
that's the bottom line also my book once
you go to quantum gravity
uh you better forget entirely
the the word time
just forget about it
you have a bunch of variables
which describe the gravitational fields
and the terminic fields whatever fields
are around whatever is
it's it's your
ingredients as far as we know today
these are the ingredients of the world
electrons quarks uh electromagnetic
field gravitation
and uh you have
relations
uh between these
which you think in terms of uh
uh there is a quantum region
if you want a space-time region
and outside
if if i if i see something
around what is the probability of seeing
that
and you don't have to say
how much time has passed which one is a
time variable
that comes out naturally
because
if the classical limit of the amplitudes
turn out to be correct they just give
generativity so in the classical limit
you have space times evolving and then
you can you know uh time is just
whatever passes around the time like
gold line but in the fundamental quantum
gravity theory just forget about time
entirely don't talk about that
time has in the various meaning in which
we
we talk about them
uh
it's just something that happens at
later
approximations the space time comes at
the large scale approximation and
oriented time comes from thermodynamics
in quantum gravity the only temporal
notion it's very weak is that you
describe process so what you describe is
a process
a
a probability amplitude of some
conjunction of variables
uh taking certain values
okay this question comes from bernardo
castro
he says carlos says that everything is
relational you may have answered this
before but carlos says everything is
relational nothing absolute i agree that
the physical that is whatever's measured
is relational as experiments have shown
but that must mean that there is an
absolute some non-physical
non-measurable layer of reality
underlying the physical
as you know
he's putting this in brackets as you
know to me that layer is mental but
carlo again says everything is
relational so
what is it relations and and so on and
so on that is turtles all the way down
or relationships all the way down how
does the notion
that everything is relational not lead
to an infinite regress
it's turtle salted way down in my
opinion
and i think what uh what
uh i mean
i i think the basic uh
i mean i know of course uh
bananas uh
uh cultural uh um ideas
he defended a rather strong version of
idealism
in which um everything is mental
and uh um
i think that the mental phenomena
are not
more
absolute more grounded
more
basic more universal than
the
the physical what we call the physical
phenomena
in fact i think if
if there is a
dependence relation the dependence
relation is other way around
so
um
if you want to understand mental
phenomena
we understand them better
starting from physical facts and from
that deriving mental phenomena
um
the other way around doesn't work in my
opinion the other way around leaves us
the impossibility of doing science we
don't derive physical phenomena from
mental phenomena but the other way
around we do
so of the two
uh
physically in a large sense
uh i don't mean material i'm in
physics systems interacting hypothesis
uh
are
more fundamental in sense of the ground
better
mental phenomena i think the
the mistake of idealism is to
don't see uh
one of the main insight
um
[Music]
in
in
in buddhist philosophy which is that the
the mental is as illusory
in in buddhist language as the external
world so the self is us
left um
less
founded
as this glass or this pen
um when i think about myself the
illusion of this is the cartesian
illusion this is evident
this is immediate this cannot be
discounted
it's wrong
um
if there's anything what is evident for
me is this pen is not me then me it's a
complicated cultural construct social
construct cultural construct what i
directly know about the world is that
there is this pen
uh i if you say well there is also you
in the world i say oh yeah it's also me
and what is me i have to i have to do so
a reflection
a story of thinking and if you read the
card
there's a logo of this idea
the card never said that um
the self
it's immediate
he said if you start doubting then you
go through a complicated cultural
process of doubting
which is due to his culture his
philosophies
and this leads him
to thinking about the self and they
think if i'm doubting them and thinking
if i'm thinking there should be
something thinking is this thinking the
self but the something thinking is not
the self it's a symbol of the processes
that matter does in my brain
so that's why i disagree with the idea
it is
why is it that the mental states and the
self are are they equivalent in your
mind in your mind are they no they're
two different things no they're two
different things of course they're two
different things the self is a it's a
it's uh um
let me not define the self uh there's
only something sure states as uh other
than men but i think that
um
what i said applied to both
and of course
the card was talking about the self
uh some people talk about mental state
in the in
um i think both are
like chairs
complicated construction we use to
describe what happens
uh you mentioned that science would be
difficult or if not impossible to do if
idealism was correct why can't we just
say see for me the way that i see
science is that science doesn't
presume a metaphysics it doesn't
actually say whether
there's an immaterial or material or
mental reality it's like a method now
people can disagree with the definition
of science
regardless why can't
idealism be correct and simply say
there are regularities to these mental
states and we see these regularities
these patterns of perception and we call
that physics
and we perform science that just as we
do or just as we currently do
sure sure no i
agree with you in in that sense
science is neutral
uh
but if i want to use
science uh
what i was saying is something much more
uh much less philosophical if you want
um if i want you to if i want
to use science to make a story about how
mental state can emerge
from configuration of the brain i've
i have a
a path that i can follow in fact many
people are following today this path i
mean there's a big
neuroscience
literature
very extremely interesting which is
precisely describing how
mental states add the notion of a self
um can emerge in a in a the complicated
uh sort of uh
neurological biological and evolutionary
story of our brain so
science allows us to make a story which
is incomplete but is in in in the
working about how mental state emerge in
the world in the same sense in which it
allows us to make a story in which how
is that a chair emerging the world i
mean how it's built by wood and and and
built by a civilization they want to sit
down and so on and so forth
while so so there's it can be done that
can be addressed by science
um
the the the the the
the
the idea
doesn't block science it's a sense to
say well okay i have this mental uh
perception or whatever and and and as i
described them
but
it doesn't allow
to do the same story to see how
um i can uh
out of a pure
mental
state
necessarily
reconstruct the
the opposite world in other words
if i'm an idealistic
i don't have any other
scientific program except the ones
that's already there i can
describe chemistry physics but not the
relation between the mental and the
physical
well if i am a materialist in some wide
sense in large sense because narrow
material is most it doesn't work i mean
the world is not paid by stones
then i have an additional
program that i can do try to make sense
of mental state on the basis of physical
systems
why can't an idealist say we can still
do that look instead of saying how does
mentality or how does mind states come
about from non-mine states like that's
essentially what you're saying before
why don't we just say well it's all
mind-like it's all pan-psychic in some
manner but certain configurations of
this mind state which
you can translate as matter certain
configurations of this matter
amplify the already existing
consciousness so you can still perform
neurobiology and neural correlates
in the same manner so why does thinking
of the world idealistically preclude
that i see it as just well you can just
say well we want to know what
configurations produce what states of
consciousness and what levels of
awareness and levels of
self-consciousness and so on
i don't know anybody in neuroscience and
thinks oh
no that's not true there are people in
neuroscience that may think that way
maybe tononi thinks in that way of um
any almost any of the theories of
consciousness that i've found
and i've been studying this for this
channel it's like
it can be applied to the universe and
then you find that there's some low
grade level of consciousness applied to
the universe as a whole anyway at least
tononi i think he's moving
in that direction i think he said that
his
iit i believe it's called integrated
information theory
implies pan psychism in some weak sense
either way you understand what i was
saying before i so you were making the
claim that idealism precludes this
understanding of the brain and
neuroscience and so on but i was saying
i don't see it as necessarily precluding
it because you can still study and just
say why is it that this configuration of
matter read configuration of mind states
produce a larger mind state or a certain
level of consciousness or certain song
yeah uh i hope you don't think i'm
fighting with you i'm just telling you
what occurs no no no no no of course of
course i know of course in fact
you're right and what you say um you're
probably right i
i maybe have not talked enough about
that um
you're you're
you're
breathing ideally is together with a
sort of pumped psychism right so you're
you're you you
you're taking this in this direction
here yeah that's some sort of pump
psychism stuff of that way
um
look
yeah
i'm not sure what it means uh
to be a very weak level
of
consciousness i mean i know what it
means in tony theory okay there's a
quantity called fee which have
big values in the brain and slow values
else
but that quantity has a
very clean uh
quantitative value
determined by configurations of matter
and the way matter might interact
so i know that jononi himself is a sort
of hidden secret idealist or
a little bit on psychist
but i'm not sure his theory is because
if his theory was
uh so
uh
it would not be possible to quantify
uh
[Music]
consciousness
on the basis of
a specific configuration of matter and
possibility of interaction of matter so
that was here's a ground there and the
ground is uh
uh
you know his physical system interacting
and affecting one another
and out of that he says in certain
configuration this
behave in a way that we call
consciousness
so i think his theory it's far more
materialistic that even what he would
like to think
remember i was saying i'm wondering oh
there's some way in which that's correct
some way in which that's correct we were
talking about this ecumenical quality
when it comes to what was his name
taloni right when it comes to tinona
now i know his theory isn't this
it's not as simple as let's imagine
billy balls and they bounce off one
another in certain
complex interactions these billiard
balls model and that creates
consciousness let's imagine it's but
let's imagine it's as simple as that
then
as you were saying
what's more fundamental the nodes or the
vertices sorry
the edges are the notes
well
then i'm wondering hmm imagine tononi's
was as simple as that that is as simple
as certain believe balls and they
interact so it's the relationship that
produces the consciousness and the balls
are fundamental but then earlier you
were saying well you can also view it as
the relationships are fundamental
so i'm wondering if in that sense
see the non-dualists don't like when i
say this i'm wondering if in some sense
physicalism and idealism
can be brought together as twin sides of
the same coin yes
yes it's a good point then
then the question is what we mean by
mental
right if by mental
uh
we mean uh uh things going on in the
mind of
people like humans or maybe
mammals or maybe
um
maybe
all
animals with neural neurons which is
larger than mammals
then
i don't think this
might be sufficient to describe what
happened on a galaxy
if by mental
we mean something that
might go wrong everywhere even when
there are no animals no neurons nothing
like that
then
mental it's an extremely
vague notion
which i'm not sure what it means if not
just a vague analogy
that
somehow
that's analogy might even be useful but
uh because again um i think the naive
material is misfront i mean the the the
uh has been shown wrong by science the
the um sort of 18 19th century idea
that there's a perfectly
full description of the world in terms
of little stones moving and bouncing one
another pulled and pulled by forces
that's not science there's physics has
moved away from that
the the because of quantum mechanics
because of field theory because of
quantum field theory and so on and so
forth
uh so the world is far more complicated
than that and if if you take if in
particular you take
ratio quantum mechanics
seriously
you think in terms of relations and how
things affect one another
now you want to call this relative uh
properties mental
you might but then it's a name
it's a name which is uh
i don't see what happened what adds
um
to the
uh
to our understanding
uh
and and what
interpreting this
so that was i think i'm an ammonist
modest in the sense that i don't think
they're two different kind of phenomena
i'm a monies like in the sense of
bertrand russell they're mental
phenomena and there are physical
phenomena mental phenomena you say oh i
see white and there's a physical
phenomena that there's a thing moving
down there i think this whole phenomena
they all belong to the same beat class
that should be explained by we we
understand more and more about all of
them but they're not two different
worlds
so if you're telling me look at some
elementary level of this distinct
very very very general way of just
understanding about the world we have
the distinction between the two
evaporates i'm happy
yeah
but is that idealism at this point
idealism is a strong way of reducing one
to the other
uh like you know
old 19th century materialism is a strong
way of reducing one to the other
um
yeah
have you thought much about the heart
problem of consciousness
yeah
so what do you believe exist
all right let's hear it's a confusion
i think it's a confusion my my take on
the half problem of consciousness this
is david chalmer uh
is that if you reach almost the point is
about we believe that
there is a hard problem of consciousness
because it is conceivable for us say to
think there is a zombie
right so it seems there is the same
physical configuration but nobody inside
and that shows
that even if we understand the physics
completely there is something missing
so this is based on what is conceivable
to us so the problem of
the heart from your consciousness
it's a problem that comes from taking
the strong
what we find conceivable not conceivable
so the kind of uh
intuition where the world view right now
but the kind of intuition that we have
about the world view right now is
exactly the kind of thing that science
shows wrong every step of the way
so
the
the heart problem consciousness shows
that we have some wrong intuition
because nature
has produced us
by solving the easy problem of caution
is not the half of consciousness so um
the easy problem of consciousness of
course is very hard which is how the
brain works
but i am deeply convinced that if you
take a copy of me
okay
equal
same nose same hair
same
neuron same atoms
same molecules same photons exactly the
same position i'm conscious my copy is
conscious it's just no way for me to
conceive
that i could be conscious and the copy
of me could be non-conscious so
therefore if we understand how the thing
works we understand what it means what
i'm saying when i'm saying i'm conscious
i don't believe there's a
hard problem of consciousness i think
there's a very hard easy problem of
consciousness namely
com understanding this uh this uh
you see
we don't understand
well if you if you if you talk to people
doing climate science or meteorological
science not climate science
a thunderstorm is not yet understood
it's very complicated phenomena to
understand because there's electric
things magnetic thing chemical thing
it's all sort of rapid and
hydrodynamics is horrendously
complicated so what exactly happened
with thunderstorm is not understood okay
does this mean that it's a hard problem
of thunderstorms no it means that this
complicated thing okay does it mean that
it's jupiter
you know the the the flashes the the
lightnings are the rage of jupiter i
mean no you don't think there's jupiter
there i think they just don't understand
what's going on
so i see
i don't see the difference between
thunderstorms and
uh
the human mind
and consciousness
let me see if i understand this
correctly if we were to imagine
duplicating you
then
you don't know
or it's unclear how that duplicate
would be
not conscious
uh the reason i'm saying is that because
uh
chalmer one of the strong arguments
for the existence of the
hard form of consciousness
in his book
is to say well imagine you have a zombie
a zombie is somebody that believes like
me
has the same aspect of me has the same
neurons as muslim synapses as me the
same
physics as me exactly the same physics
including down to the atomic level
but there is no consciousness so he says
imagine this thing okay
and look if you can imagine that it
means you can imagine that consciousness
is separated from the physical something
else something above the physical
because you can have the same physical
with or without consciousness so this
proves it
so he proves that constantly something
separate from the physical
on the basis
of this zombie argument think that there
is a copy of you um
which is uh there's nobody inside
there's no self person
but they think there was
exactly me i wouldn't understand what it
means there's nobody inside they could
talk to him hey carlo how how do you
feel i mean i'm the right one or you're
the right one he could fight about that
and you know make jokes about that
of course it wouldn't make any sense to
know which ones the right and which ones
are false
um
so he would be conscious under all
possible
way that i couldn't understand
consciousness so his proof is based on
an intuition that i don't have
the existence of zombies have you ever
played virtual reality
like put on a vr headset yeah yeah a bit
a little bit yeah okay the reason why is
i don't find it so inconceivable i can
imagine putting on a vr headset and
seeing my wife or seeing you or even
myself and even being able to look in
someone's brain and it's generated with
a computer of course i would have no id
like we can just
what's the word procedurally generate so
we can procedurally generate the brain
as i zoom in and zoom out i can't even
do that physically like i can't zoom
into your brain physically but
regardless i don't see it as totally
inconceivable that there can be this
simulated copy that it itself we would
say is not conscious and it can talk i
can touch it and see the blood fall out
from wherever i'm touching with my
scissors or whatever maybe
why is it inconceivable to consider a
philosophical zombie
even in vr
well
let's let's push it if in vr
you could uh
create a person
and this person doesn't just look like a
person and you touch him and and blood
comes out but also answer your questions
and also have a memory and also have a
a way of reflecting and everything and
and blah blah blah blah blah blah and
all the memories and all the complexity
of me
i think that whatever computer
is implementing all that
you know it has memory it talks about i
i remember that i'm this i'm that i see
you
that's his
a real person how about let's remove the
memory and the reflective
characteristics because there's some
people who are have are mentally
challenged by birth they cannot develop
a reflective property
even babies
so let's imagine that we would say a
baby is conscious a baby can feel
a baby has no memories let's imagine
this this baby has no memory so let's
simulate that then
uh
i'm attacking i'm just telling you what
occurs to me i'm sorry no no no of
course i like it
i like this
um
[Music]
okay so
feeling
it's uh um philosophical babies instead
of philosophical zombies just the zombie
babies
so you mentioned memory and reflective
capabilities i'm just saying remove that
right so um
i think that uh
uh
let's separate the question in into if
you
if you have a
uh so let's forget virtual reality for a
moment if you have a
um
a
an artificial baby
um
that behaves like a baby and uh and uh
in all the complexity of a baby i think
it's soft it suffers it would suffer
i would not hurt
it
i would resist from hurting it
of course
if you give me a little robot
which when are you kicking he says wow
yeah okay
i will kick it because i know that
there's a huge difference between that
robot and a baby but is the actual
difference
that
uh establish
my
my believing
that there is suffering always not afro
suffering
if if it would uh
because i think that suffering is
nothing else
then just you know
the the baby having a ball a body a
brain and and and all these things and
that generates sufferers
uh
so
you know the cart is so i don't know if
this is a full story or a real story but
he he believed that only humans have
consciousness he would kick his dog
because he thought that uh
i don't know if he's true uh because i i
read that he was very attached to his
dog so just the things that things
wouldn't wouldn't go together well
um
but if he if it is true i think it was a
mistake i don't think there is any
dog suffering less
real as a mental state than a human
suffering
i mean we we might prefer killing a dog
than killing a man but that's a
different story
now the virtual reality simulation of
pain
you're right that's more tricky
because
because
what does it mean that uh
you have a software
that simulate the entire body of the as
a body
uh
being hurt and suffering that i don't
know
that's just bustling okay now rapid fire
again just a few more so this nickel
ns and he wrote the word he or she wrote
the word phi econ i don't know if that
means physics economist
regardless
here she said i want to thank carlo
robelli a lot when i was doing my
masters 14 years ago i ended up with a
similar idea as relational quantum
mechanics but i didn't have the
mathematical ability to pursue it and
i've been following him since question
one what is his view regarding the paper
quantum principle of relativity by
andres dragon and artur eckert
are you aware of that paper
quantum principle well thank you thank
you for watching she says no i'm sorry
i'm not aware of this paper so um
if if he or she thinks it's interesting
send me an email and i'm gonna read it i
will send it to you his question or her
question number two is what is his view
regarding the work of brian sungle
uh
which center is this one is one of uh of
this is brian swingle i don't know i
don't know if that's a physicist i don't
know who that is i'm sorry
i'm sorry i don't know same okay good
sir knight i love carlo a great man to
explain complex ideas simply to a person
like myself he said before that he took
psychedelics when he was young i think
it was lsd
and it was a satori moment which helped
him think about time in physics in novel
ways has he done psychedelics since and
if so has it given him any new insights
or confirmed his theories in any way
um at this psychedelic said in my youth
a few times
ten times maybe uh no more
uh
15 maybe um
and then i have not
done it since uh and i don't know maybe
i i will in the future um nowadays
things
so what the whole thing about
psychedelics is changing it's changing
very rapidly
so
things might become simpler uh now
um
it was important for me it was a very
strong
experience like
many people who had it say
do you recall your dosage
no
um but comparing to descriptions uh
which you find in literature was
certainly quite high oh yeah
wow yeah
yeah uh
definitely high um
i mean
compared to the strongest uh
accounts of of of
similar experience that you find
nowadays easily
in in all sorts of literature
um
you know
steve jobs the the head
of apple said that to take lsd this
youth was one of the two most important
strong experiences of his life i i think
i could subscribe that it was very
strong
um it definitely did not i did not
get direct physical ideas by taking nst
so i don't
suggest you know take lsd so you write
good paper in physics that's not the way
it works
um i was young and it was many many
years from there to the actual physics
uh i did however
i believe it's true that
it did affect
my way of thinking about reality
especially um in a sort of uh
liberatory sense i mean thought about i
came out i was young again i was
i guess the first time i was 16.
i came out with from that experience
saying thinking wait a minute what we
usually think about space and time and
matter and energy and mind and me and
the world and that
uh
that's just one way of thinking about
things maybe there are all sorts of
other ways of thinking about that and my
brain is can can view things
very very differently for a while so it
might be possible to think differently
so
i came out from that experience maybe it
was also the culture at the time
with an extremely
large a purely flexibility
about
possibilities right right i can imagine
that
in terms of you know political ideas
moral ideas social ideas
but also physical idea i mean i
i had a distinctive sense that this
organization in space and in time that
we
usually perceive about the world could
just change with a little chemical
so we are clinical so
you know why should one be better than
the other
um
and this stayed with me
and i think that one
first
it gave me curiosity
because when i later on 10 years later
i studied physics
and read that you know einstein
discovered that simultaneity is not
well defined
i said well about it this i you know i
do i knew that things were more
complicated than what they looked at the
first side
um and then when i studied generativity
quantum mechanics i was ready to accept
very easily the idea
uh that the world could perhaps be
profoundly different than i would
imagine of it didn't scare me the idea
because somehow it's an idea that had
confronted so in that sense i think it
was very useful um for this no more than
that
did you get to a state of a temporality
where you didn't feel like there was
time passing yeah or eternity even like
infinite time passing yeah that's one of
the
uh
i say more common
um
things that people say
namely that uh time it's uh uh the sense
of time is completely
uh
destroyed in in many ways i mean i would
say the simplest way
which i remember very well away from
very beginning is just you know having
the sense of watching the looking at the
at the watch
and then you know
hours and hours later watching it again
and uh realizing that one minute had
passed so wait a minute all this
happened in one minute i mean my god
which is one of the things people get
scared
right so one one of the things i mean
the only the problem with lsd if you get
scared
and you
you get terrorized and it's extremely
psychologically dangerous yeah it can be
very bad it doesn't happen often but
it's uh
i think it's the only real problem in
these things the only real danger of
this is having a
couple a few very bad hours which may
look very wrong and then one of the
reasons you get scared is when you
realize that you know you feel the time
is passing but it's not passing outside
you you feel trapped
oh my god i'm here and then come out of
you okay it's because here for me time
is it's it's passing and outside is not
passing so that's one of the security
but that's
extraordinary strong distortion of the
sense of how much time is fast it's just
one aspect of it because uh
i think the sense that people talk about
that it's a sense of completely destroy
what it means by temporal organization
of the world
and the other common thing is this
distinction between yourself and the
outside right it's a basic
it's a basic
category in our think about valid so
there's me in the rest me it's me and
the rest is rest
and this is something which uh
it was very clear in my experiences is
common in many reports of this
experience is that you use
the sense of you as a self separate
distinct from um
from the rest it's very strong it's very
physical the lsd experience is a very
uh it's it's a very
powerful thing in fact i remember
spending days and days after that
sort of under the shock it was not bad
but it was also
disturbing tiring
i mean my mind had kept going back to
that for what has happened that means oh
my god what what has happened where am i
who am i what is
um
not unpleasant for me it was never been
unpleasant it has always been pleasant
uh very pleasant extremely pleasant i
had a i i faced it without preparation
but my friend was with me who had no
preparation and no
experience either
actually said the right thing at the
very beginning and was near to me
the right thing being don't be scared
whatever happens don't worry just let it
go and uh just don't resist
and just be aware that then you come
back and
whatever happens you back yourself so
um
that's very assured because he said
exactly right i think the moment in
which i got scared i remembered that and
said okay i'll trust him let things go
and let this strange experience go over
you
um
i loved it it stayed with me and somehow
in the moment in which i am in deep [ __ ]
which we all go through in our life
i remember that moment there is it's
it's calming to me it says good luck i
look at my hands the way i looked at my
hands in that and i
i have a sense of
separation from reality and
and the beauty of reality they start the
beauty of reality in front of me just
how it is
um
which i
remember as a gift of that particular
moment that stays with me all my life
was it a moment of utter peace or
euphoria
like what was what would be the word
that you would characterize it
these people would say positive but
there's so many different senses of the
word positive
no we're not called peace we're not
called serene
i was not called euphoria
either
um i don't know emotionally
it was uh
completely overwhelming
surprise
and a sense of
violent
almost joy at some moment
oh wow i feel overwhelmed by the beauty
of things
and like seeing things for the first
time it's a
strange thing like like if i was oh my
god i've never seen that but this is
just you know my hand or a tree believe
anything
um
and by overwhelmed by the beauty of it
and be aware that you know this is just
a leaf and that's i could look at it as
an incredibly beautiful thing it's just
me and that's my heart opening up and
just exploding but
it's notoriously hard to describe those
experiences everybody says so and now
there is a growing literature
because finally
scientists can study these substances
after it was forbidden to study this
science substances for 40 years it's
completely stupid because why should you
know people study poisons or you know
heroin
why shouldn't you study this sciences
um
so i hope that now the very body
take away this silly
yes yeah yeah
for beating
studying these things
so it didn't directly help you with
physics but it helped you with
entertaining ideas that other people
would consider unpalatable such as time
doesn't exist or so-and-so is relational
rather than real
exactly
exactly so in other words
lee smalling you need to give lee
smalling some lsd to dissuade him of his
ideas of the primacy
and that's what i'm going to read
between the lines okay
last two questions last two
go to do you know who
whitehead is alfred north whitehead
yeah okay so this question comes from
aaron haidari says ravelli seems to
reflect
a lot of the pen
theist
process philosophy that whitehead talks
about i wonder if he's familiar with
whitehead and what he
thinks of this more organic view of
reality
yeah
well um
i i got to know what had precisely
because other people already
pointed out similarities
especially
thinking
reality as a process
if not that entities
um
hint it is with property but
happening of things so
processes before things
um
definitely there is this resonance and
the similarity and i'm sure that's
you know my way of thinking might have
been affected by by him or by people who
were affected by him
um
so i read i i started reading
uh some of his books because of that
because people pointed out this
analogies
and i i saw the analogy so i saw the
similarities i try to get something
useful from it but there is a size
there is a
an aspect of it
which i don't
connect to
um
which is this more organic or even
spiritualist
right there's a somehow
the way he faces the problems i i
couldn't
in spite of definite uh
similarities in this main idea that we
we describe the world as a process but
not
but but i'm a deeply a physicist
um
a physicalist
but i think that the the the physical
description of the world that we have
now it's it's it's very good as it is um
it doesn't need to
uh
to be reinforced by
by other pieces it has to be better
understood perhaps
and and i try to read what we know about
the world at that level
um from the physics itself and i think
it's not contradictory with a higher
level description of the world
okay with the ones given by biology by
sociology by psychology by you know
everything i think there's a there's
coherence we don't understand many of
the intermediate steps
uh but there's clearance between these
different pictures of of of the world
well of course we need a higher level
ones because uh
because we cannot i cannot describe my
girlfriends who are using maxwell
equations that doesn't work
there's no contradiction between she
being made by atoms uh
governed by the maxwell equations
and you know she being somebody i love
and she loves me and we interact on the
level of our
emotions
uh they're just different different
levels of description some which works
better as some aggregate of things and
some which works better
um
and and
i don't see any a priori contradiction
between that and there's no need
to um
to add higher level notions to the
fundamental notions
when it comes to the problem of quantum
gravity or theories of everything or
grand unified theories do you think that
what's missing is a whole conceptual
paradigm shift or is it just it's a
mathematical complication it can be
solved
without changing our view of what
reality is much
like what do you think is holding us
back which one is it
i think it's there's nothing holding
back i think we have theories of quantum
gravity and that might be right um
so we don't need to go look for new
ideas in quantum gravity we have to we
go we have to go try to figure out if
the ideas we have a good or bad
um i think this idea that all quantum
gravity is such a mystery that we need
some new idea why do we need some new
idea i mean we have theories the reason
we're not sure is that we cannot test
them not because they're wrong or
they're bad
group point to gravity is one i don't
want to say this is the right theory
because it might be wrong theory might
another one may be right
or maybe we haven't yet you know
understood the relation between this or
maybe i mean i have the reasons to think
that string theory is not good it looks
going to gravity is good but
for quantum gravity itself we have
decent theories of the the missing staff
the piece pieces we don't understand
well
but i don't
share this idea oh my god we're missing
a big idea we're not missing a big idea
to articulate something like loop
quantum gravity you need a big
conceptual shift because there's no
background space no background time as i
said before you have to accept the idea
that the fundamental shift of the world
you don't use the time variable so it's
already there it has been worked out is
is decades of discussions
that have come out with a
a possible story
we have more than one possible stories
because there are other alter possible
alternatives is you know symptomatic
safety the string theory and
and others
uh but we have things about quantum
gravity what we miss
is you know filling up details
you know look what it's hard to do
calculation of scattering string
theories how to understand how to come
down four dimensions nobody really has
done it yet
uh the the you know the schemes ideas
but the body goes from the big theory
down to the to the standard model
um
i i would not look for other
why should we look for other ideas that
then we just you know put them in a
drawer and we don't know how to
we need
smart ideas for checking those theories
and and that's what many people doing
working on black holes working on early
universe
trying to see if some of the theories we
have can be tested
just so you know that question was from
dong hyun yoon i just wanted to make
sure to say that and the last last
question is craig reed tcr i'd be
curious to know what he thinks of nema
arkani ahmed's amplitude and his lecture
on the end of space time i don't think
i've ever heard rovelli comment on it
lima is great um it's a uh it's a
powerful thinker it's a great
mathematician i had
i remember a very good
afternoon in princeton talking with him
um
i
there's a book that just came out
um which is a
big thick book with interviews of people
in uh
quantum gravity
uh of all different
uh
i can just look it up if you give me a
keyword so i can tell the audience what
it is it is sitting here let me go get
it yeah great
conversations on quantum gravity
wonderful
edited by jacom armas a-r-m-a-s
and uh it's it's a big thick book um
of interviews
detailed interviews of uh
a large uh number of people um
doing quantum gravity it's a bit boring
because it's a big thing with everybody
you know same question so
to but i'm going systematically through
it and reading all of it
because i'm curious to actually know
what the various people and it's
remarkable they're very
diverse ideas
and i read uh the one of nina uh
academic uh in in detail of course um
because his alphabetical order
is the first
um i'm just almost halfway past halfway
through the book
and uh so i'm i'm thinking
while reading the various uh
people i'm curious to know what all the
people think i'm i'm reading and of
course i'm
i'm checking what they say with respect
to what i think and i'm trying to get
the ideas that i don't know and trying
to argue
so it's a very good exercise for me um
now
i think that uh
he belongs to um
that
uh
part of the community
who um has fell in love with the
maldecinna idea of the bulk boundary
and then later on has given
a sort of an ideological basis on that
by an argument
that says that in quantum gravity
we have to go to infinity
uh to
to define the theory
because there are physical reasons
for which we cannot make a measurement
in the bulk so to say
so all the actual measurements are uh
and uh in fact in the book he articulate
that because this is good because he
he explains his you know his deep
motivations for doing that
now i'm convinced that this argument is
wrong um
uh
because it presupposes the space-time
and uh
because uh it uh
it mixes
uh the need for the coherence for making
measurements with the distance in space
so they i think it's technically wrong
and but this is has become a dogma in in
his word especially in princeton um
that you can only describe things from
from a very large distance from a
syntactic distance
so he's going entirely in that direction
and that's why he doesn't
think that loop quantum gravity might
work because loop control it is a
description
of quantum space time locally in in a
small region so i'm i'm here
i i make an experiment a quantum
experiment and i compute what comes out
without need to go to
centopia
um
so uh
you know these people are going doing
technical work but that's the assumption
uh on which also his work on the on the
um
scattering amplitudes
it's good but it's not
it's not in the four-dimensional
generativistic world in which we live so
uh i i don't think that the solution of
quantum gravity and the property of
quantum gravity is in fancy mathematics
um
i think it's in just writing the things
properly i mean there's a look on the
guide it defines scattering amplitudes
they're very hard to compute
but they're there
and
does that without going to the boundary
inside space-time
and the
objection here has to look into gravity
i think they're they're wrong i wish we
could uh you know with all these people
i wish we could sit down
and uh
maybe i'm arrogant but i think i could
convince them the sum of the assumptions
that they are wrong
of course almond center i may have
are wrong and i wish they could tell me
why
carlo
professor
thank you so much
it's been quite a good
quite a journey for over four hours been
long quite a journey you pushed me to
say a lot of ideas
into a lot of the things i've been
thinking so i liked i liked very much i
loved this interview
the podcast is now finished if you'd
like to support conversations like this
then do consider going to patreon.com
c-u-r-t
j-a-i-m-u-n-g-a-l that is kurt jaimungle
it's support from the patrons and from
the sponsors that allow me to do this
full-time every dollar helps
tremendously thank you